it's a matrix attack against Russell
Brand at least that's what Andrew tatus
called it and I do think it's kind of
suspect it's very strange that all of a
sudden out of the blue you've got all of
these accusations coming out against
Russell Brand and so now there are two
conspiracy theories I love this the
first is that Russell Brand a known
abuser knew himself that these
allegations would soon come to haunt him
so he cultivated a following of
anti-establishment personalities and
fans so that when it finally came down
upon him he would immediately say quick
everyone defend me that's an absolutely
absurd conspiracy theory the other is
that the media machine is going after
Russell Brand because of a viral clip on
Bill Maher where he roasts big Pharma
and his consistent anti-establishment
attacks have resulted in him being the
target of the machine or the Matrix as
Andrew take calls it I think it's funny
that he calls it that uh look I don't
know we'll go through this we'll talk
about it but it I I would lean more
towards it's very suspicious that across
the board front pages everywhere going
after Russell Brand because he's not
Epstein when they ignore Epstein and
Target Russell Brand it makes you wonder
when they ignore Weinstein for 20 plus
years and then they go after Russell
Brand it makes you wonder granted their
allegations so we'll read through this
then we got big news about this F-35
that apparently just vanished they did
find it the debris field but here's the
craziest thing they're ordering a stand
down on all aircraft because of a series
of disasters that just happened
I mean it may be premature to say but
get what go broke I guess for the US
Armed Forces we'll talk about all that
and more before we do head over to
timcast.com click timcast irlx Miami and
pick up your tickets to the event
October 6th in Miami it's gonna be
awesome we got Patrick Bet David Donald
Trump Jr Matt Gates Lou gradkowski I
will be there Ian cross will be there
plus we have a whole bunch of special
guests who are going to start announcing
very very soon we're gonna have a
pre-show we're gonna have an after show
and now I'm just gonna I don't know if
I'm supposed to announce any of this
stuff just yet Alex Stein of course is
going to be there he's going to be doing
a uh I guess we call it stand up I don't
know how he describes it he's been doing
a a 15-minute set on stage to warm up
just before the show it's going to be
hilarious and there's a bunch of really
high profile people who are there who
are not currently slated we may announce
I kind of don't want to be like oh
here's a big list of all of our friends
from the show who are going to be there
because maybe they just want to hang out
meet people but uh we'll put up the list
when we when we're for sure everyone's
cool with being a shouted out as being
there and I think for the most part the
best thing is if you're an Elite member
we're doing a meet up 3 P.M that day
location to be disclosed the last minute
because security reasons and uh if you
come to the event we're going to see you
there we're going to be hanging out I
don't know about everybody else but I'll
tell you I'll be hanging out it'll be a
lot of fun also if you're at timcast.com
click join us to become a member
support our work directly and you'll get
access to our exclusive uncensored
members only shows plus the Discord
server where like-minded individuals
have started building stuff they host
their own show so after the after show
there's an additional conversation with
like-minded individuals that keep these
conversations going all night so really
you should sign up because uh what
they're building the timcast members
Community is really really amazing you
guys rock shout out smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this share with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about all this and more
is adelita's way we're happy to be here
it's been great who are you what are you
doing so I'm Rick the Jesus I'm the
singer songwriter of Adelitas Way uh
we're on tour right now I love God I
love my family and I love our country so
I'm at the point now where I'm willing
to do anything for the people I love
right on and we also have another member
of adelita's way what's up I'm Trevor
Stafford I play drums for adelita's way
you guys uh I don't know you're a rock
band you had well you had a bunch of
like big hits yeah we've had uh we've
had what three number 1 hits we've got
two Gold Records we got an independent
gold record yeah independent gold record
that's a big one for us so thank you to
our fans for making that possible but
we're just trying to pave the way for
Indie artists man we're we're you know
the the typical story we're we're
abusing the record industry uh
definitely mentally and financially and
uh now you know they they spent years
trying to kind of throw dirt on us but I
think now they've given up on that and
just said all right this band's gonna
have success and we've become one of the
most successful independent acts and we
really want to just be uh you know paved
the way for other artists who were
looking to do this or maybe if they feel
this way they feel like they've been
defeated maybe it can give them a
resurrection plus we got to build
culture and so it's awesome that you
guys you know you went independent
you're doing your own thing you're
fighting the culture war and uh glad to
have you here should be fun so thanks
for hanging out Anna Claire's hanging
out hey I'm Hannah clip remlo I'm a
writer for timcast.com I'm really
looking forward to tonight Ian's here
too yes and talking about building
culture man we just we just pumped out a
song I did a song with Adelita sway
called hour featuring Ian Crossland I
saw it's tight oh it's hot it's Ty's
powerful we recorded it from across the
country too and sent and sent the uh the
data what we did the whole thing was
interesting because we were last time we
were on the show we actually started the
process here we were like what can we do
so we we just spent a couple hours down
there you know doing what we all love
messing around music and then it
inspired us to go back and write an
entire song and then you know I remember
you in there just jamming and and
singing
we've done some sweet hook that was a
nice hook dude I'm bummed you didn't
ground with me out there though let's do
it let's do it grounding we weren't
breathing together oh I grounded earlier
today did you good work yeah you look
smooth yeah and it's pawpaw season so we
went out and grabbed some fresh pop it's
the perfect time too oh they were
delicious so usually we forget and then
we go out there and they're they're like
mushy and you're like well let's try and
find some good ones right now they are
perfect
pawpaw's hillbilly banana it's an
Appalachian thing tastes like mango and
banana combined it's it's it it's crazy
it's like mango it's nuts but uh we also
got Carter the Buns tonight very fitting
that I'm here filling in for search I
saw you guys out the window and that's
now I know we all were doing but yeah
just last year we were all at Blue Ridge
Rockfest together so I'm really excited
to be here let's do it all right let's
jump into that first story ladies and
gentlemen they're coming for Russell
Brand the New York Times Russell Brand
cancels comedy dates after sexual
assault allegations the comedian was
scheduled to perform three dates in
Britain this month now they've been
postponed he's also been dropped from
his talent agency shows on Channel 4
have been pulled there's pressure on the
BBC and Netflix to pull his shows yo
they are coming after Russell Brand with
Force I have not seen uh in a long time
I mean look they come after him and
apparently there is a criminal
investigation underway as well but I
hear people talking about on Twitter and
Andrew Tate says Matrix attack that's
what he calls it some people are
comparing this to uh what they did to
Andrew Tate but I think what they did to
Andrew tank what they're doing to him is
a bit more extreme they're accusing him
of like outright trafficking and stuff
like this but I do find it very
interesting that uh Russell Brand is
being so heavily targeted for one simple
reason
Epstein has been accused of doing uh so
much more and for such a long period of
time to the point where he was actually
criminally prosecuted where you actually
had ABC News Amy rohrback saying we got
him we got this story and then dropping
it
when you have someone as devious and
malicious evil as Epstein and they do
nothing and then you have Russell Brand
and they're like did you know that 10
years ago 15 years ago in one instance
they're saying it was 17 years ago it's
like two decade old allegations and
apparently I don't even know if these
allegations some of them are not even
criminal they're like he was abusive
emotionally like this is all part of the
story you know they're they're
destroying they're trying to destroy
this guy's career and pull him off out
of the face of the of the of of of
mainstream conversations and and
commentary
for decades-old allegations I just I
gotta say right off the bat it seems
kind of strange so I do want to play for
you this clip here because this is
sparking conspiracy number one
Simon atiba Says many are now saying
this clip this video clip might be why
Russell Brand is being attacked watch
let's play this clip from Real Time with
Bill Maher this thing's probably got I
don't know 50 million views because it's
being reposted everywhere but here you
go
yeah
he said he's gonna give him facts
I wouldn't have mentioned it I'm English
and you know that politeness is our
fundamental religion
but they do pertain to this issue so may
I say something if they're inconvenience
you I'll stop saying them the pandemic
created at least 40 new far big Pharma
billionaires pharmaceutical corporations
like moderna and Pfizer made a thousand
dollars of profit every second from the
covid-19 vaccine more than two-thirds of
Congress receive campaign funding from
pharmaceutical companies in the 2020
election Pfizer chairman Albert baller
told Time magazine in July 2020 that his
company was developing a covered vaccine
for the good of humanity not for money
and of course Pfizer made a hundred
billion dollars in profit in 2022. oh
and may I just mention that finally and
these are this is also a fact that you
the American public funded the
development of that the German public
funded the bio and Tech vaccine when it
came to the profits they took the
profits when it came to the funding you
paid for the funding all I'm querying is
this yes is if you have an economic
system in which pharmaceutical companies
benefit hugely from medical emergencies
where a military industrial complex
benefits from war where an energy
companies benefit from energy crises you
are going to generate states of
Perpetual crisis for the interests of
Ordinary People yes and separate from
the interests of the elite and he hit
the nail on there with the Hamilton
people are saying like that's it right
there I'm not gonna go I don't I think
it's silly to say this one clip did it
because I think I don't know once it's
clip from do we even know when the show
was I'm pretty sure it was from a while
ago but I will say it's that kind of
sentiment that's going to make you a lot
of enemies I'm still waiting for my
check that's for sure well are you guys
sponsored I know all these media
companies are you know sponsored by
Pfizer all these news outlets I'll tell
you this could be first of all you know
innocent till proven guilty how many
times have you seen allegations go
against an athlete someone who who uh
seems to be not part of the whole Matrix
they call right someone that's not in in
bed with the elites how many times have
you seen the allegations come the name
drug through the mud for two a year or
two all to all to find out in the end
that there's no charges nothing ever
happens but then what happens is you you
get uh associated with being a rapist
you get if say Russell Brand say that
that this goes on for some time
everything you know nothing happens
right oh innocent nothing really that we
see that's gonna get him jail time
people are still gonna say oh didn't he
rape women yeah anytime his name comes
in an article
Russell Brand who was accused of this
whether or not anything's actually
proven right they'll put the commas
Russell brand comma who was accused of
multiple rapes comma right and it taints
your legacy and and I think he he says a
whole lot more than than this this is
big he's he's you know obviously saying
information that people may not know
that that's good to know and and I think
uh they're going after him because
they're trying to set the tone that if
you Revolt if you're going against
anything that we're displeased with
right now in time this could be you you
could be the one next that that's
getting this you know injust system I
think that the justice system is
becoming
um you know completely favorable to the
elites who can kind of do whatever they
want I think it's always been kind of
like it's getting worse though they're
doing it in front of our faces now now
it's just like you know with jaywalking
we don't like this guy look at oh who'd
he vote for look at him yeah give him
two years in prison and then someone
over here does the worst thing you could
possibly do and and it's just somehow
they program all of our minds to not
care that they kill all these people or
do I think this could simply be if you
are Outside The Establishment and
mainstream narrative you are not allowed
to be in the establishment and the
mainstream so this could be for a lot of
reasons one uh super teachers popped in
the OMG Puppies made a good point saying
that he's anti-war he's anti-ukraine war
and for the UK I mean they're they're
more serious they're sending depleted uh
depleted uranium tank Busters I think
they're called these and and Putin said
that these are basically nuclear weapons
so you've got someone in the UK doing
that they excise him from everything
this is their way to reduce his
influence I don't think they care about
the aftermath they're basically saying
he should not be on mainstream
television he should not be on Netflix
BBC Channel 4 he should be in the in the
gutters of society along with Alex Jones
and you name it they should now be
platformed as it were how do you get
someone off of a network if Russell
Brand is featured in these TV shows they
generate attention for him and that
brings people to his podcast where he
outrights says we should not be funding
War we should not be funding big
pharmaceutical companies okay you got a
problem well you can't just sever the
contracts you have with them unless you
have a morality violation now you have
your morality Clause violation against
Russell Brand impropriety and it's like
why would his talent agency drop him
overnight it's like come on there's not
a conviction it doesn't matter this is
their way of saying we are removing him
from polite Society because we don't
like the things he has to say and it's
funny because they they none of this
came out when he's playing the role of a
guy that all he does is drink through
drugs and have sex right there we want
to represent this guy he's the perfect
guy over the years that he spent talking
about his sex addiction in his stand-up
comedy right like right he was open
about the fact that he lived essentially
a degenerate lifestyle I mean it was
fueled by addiction it's complicated I
get that but no one thought ah yes while
his initial star was Rising I should
come forward with these allegations
right he has been a popular name for a
long time why now well when the casting
comes in and and the casting says
looking for sex addicted rock star you
know literally his agent's like that's
my guy you know I have the perfect guy
and then he you find out now they're
trying to say he does these things in
real life and you're like I kind of
figured that was the case anyway but
they're just trying to put a Bad spin on
what I think
um I want to see it I want to see that
well I mean accusing the dude of rape I
think is completely over the top right
right you might look at him and be like
10 years later yeah but like to to
assume that he has these behaviors
because of his character and his Persona
and stuff it's like well no I might I
might assume that he's at like crazy
clubs and parties and doing nasty stuff
but not abusing people I mean that's
like accusing him of like I wouldn't
assume Russell Brand's committing crimes
against people you know what I mean you
know it's crazy that two people can get
drunk black out drunk have sex for not
even know they did it because they're
blacked out then the next morning the
woman can say I didn't I didn't agree to
that I wasn't cognitively but a man
can't if if I if that happened to a
woman and they're both blackout drunk
the woman can say I was raped but the
man can't say I was raped which is
terrible right like I thought we I
thought we're the feminists I thought we
were all gender equal why can't men well
did it too but the fault is always on
the man no but didn't someone do this
there was a guy who came out and said
that he was raped by some woman like
abruptly yeah this happened once and
everyone I can't remember who this was
everybody was like uh oh you see the
game he's playing he's gonna be the
first one to make the accusation so that
he can't be accused because he's he's
the one making the accusation I can't
remember there's a story maybe people in
the chat will remember I mean similar
stuff comes up when you get you know
high school students who sleep with
their teacher and everyone's like wow
great job but if it's a girl they're
like that man was out of control which
of course in both scenarios the adult is
in the wrong there here's something
funny too people need to watch out
before I mention this on my morning show
they say that Russell Brand one of the
accusers was 16 at the time and you're
like what oh that's that's crazy but you
got to ask yourself first how old was
Russell Brand because imagine you know
if someone came out was like Ian
Crossland dated a 16 year old when he
was 16. that's actually true right so
it's like the saying Ian Ian Crossing
dated a 16 year old people were like
whoa that's crazy
this is a fact and we need to see if
this is actually you could just say see
we're hearing hearsay right now I want
to see the facts I want to see the case
I'm not just going to call him rapist
and then two years later like he
actually never did it and then right
he's still this rape but I I don't want
to say one more thing too uh Russell
Brown was 31 at the time of the
allegations of the 16 year old and so
it's it's like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna give the guy a free pass either
there's accusations innocent until
proven guilty I don't think he should
lose his job at all just because his
claims are coming out and they're not
even I think these claims for the most
part are not even claims claims of
criminality I think there may be a
couple but in the instance of a 16 year
old I think that the age of consent as
all the news reports are saying legal
doesn't mean good like 31 year old
hitting up a 16 year old kind of weird
assuming it's true but criminal and then
it's a question of I mean are we gonna
look dude is this 20 years ago if the
dude committed a crime or whatever we
hold them accountable I just think
when you have Epstein and they don't
care at all and weirdly none of his
victims seem to be allowed to come
forward at all ever what a couple of
them do and then we suddenly they'd get
where's that Client List yeah Maria
farmer she's got a I'm just the one
listen to her it's just amazing what
were you saying Ian I don't I don't I
don't know I didn't read this part of
the story you mentioned that like a
journalist reached out to these women I
was people were saying that he's being
targeted I'm like well let's look into
it and then I looked into it and
apparently a journalist took it upon
herself to contact these women and be
like do you want to be in a story about
Russell do you want to accuse Russell
Brand do you want to and like ask these
people to come out and I don't know if
this is 100 I haven't like been able to
confirm or deny because I don't know the
behind the scenes workings but it sounds
like it was a reporter that kind of put
all this together I just wanna I wanna I
wanna say uh I'll say two quick things
because we we got some great messages in
the chat uh this is a amtru said that he
said you said it to him they're going to
go after lawyers for doing nothing next
to be media personalities yeah I didn't
think this would be like in relation to
j6 right I didn't mean like someone like
Russell Brand I meant people who are
actively promoting j6 but I do want to
say this is modern assassination
the way they the way they target people
uh uh powerful Elites corrupt
individuals mafias whatever back in the
day was assassination
they that that's reserved now for
extreme circumstances related to
International conflict War what they do
now you can observe with Julian Assange
falsely accused of rape to Tang to the
media you then got all of these Intel
asset media agencies prominent major
media they kept saying Julian Assange
raped a woman he was accused of rape
none of it was true he was never accused
of rape that never happened right then
they then they lock him up for it and he
knows the charges are bunk and so then
he goes to the Ecuadorian Embassy and
then the media runs the attack again and
again and again Julian Assange flees
rape charges rape charges there was
never a rape charge he was never accused
of raping anybody the media just kept
lying about it because character
assassination is how you do it if you
assassinate someone let's say and and
look I love this you know the media is
going to be like conspiracy theories
dude come on assassinations get to get
busted all the time we know what happens
the dark web has these things if you're
if they are trying to take out someone
who's politically powerful or
influential and that person dies they
become a martyr people paint pictures of
their face on a wall so the modern
technique is destroy the image of the
person first and then make make it
unacceptable or Unthinkable to say their
name or cite them yeah I would call This
Modern banishment where you used to
actually throw them out of the country
now you debank them and make their make
them Asian drop them and stuff it
doesn't matter where they live they're
just not welcome to be part of the
society and you're getting banished for
what for for trying to start uh uh or
try to inform the civilian in trying to
start a revolution of some sorts for us
because we know at this point that we're
fed up right all of us uh there's a lot
to be fed up about and it it brings fear
for for communities it brings fear for
leaders to step out and say we're not
going to take any more of this we're
standing up to this and it's going to
make less people want to want to you
know kind of put their put their foot
down and and revolt against
the abuse of power that's been happening
uh extremely the past few years I mean
it's been happening our whole life our
whole lifetime but it's really really
getting done in front of our face more
recently and I've got little kids to
raise so I I want them to to grow up in
a good civilization right so they can
just do this to you they can just you
know 30 years for January 6th which was
obviously
planned and and kind of scripted out to
happen that way and then and then look
what they do they they're setting an
example for anybody that wants to be a
part of any form of Revolution that's a
problem because we may need a revolution
at some point during our lifetime I like
how yeah I think elon's effectively
creating a legal Revolution by
reorganizing the business and
infrastructure of the world with like
building out the electric car thing
getting us up into space with reusable
Rockets so it's kind of like you know
the technology is the revolution the way
we communicate is the message itself the
meaning is the message is the meaning I
think that was a really famous quote by
uh I'm not sure who said that is there
is oh sorry no I'm gonna pull up this
tweet we have this tweet from Brian
krasis Marshall mcluhan was the guy
sorry Tim keep going we have this tweet
from Brian krasenstein he says I see a
lot of people claiming that the media
and the establishment habitat for
Russell Brand and that's why these
allegations came out do you know which
what's more likely now I'm going to
pause here because the allegations he's
making are both the same allegation that
Russell Brand knew he did bad things and
created an audience that would challenge
the establishment
and then he says or did he do the same I
think he made a mistake in this one but
I want to play this video that he that
he posted this is the most insane
conspiracy theory and it it's I it
actually makes me think this is a quote
unquote Matrix attack against Russell
Brand let me play the clip for you both
he's known
since me too started that there are
women out there who have stuff on him
and that it's only a matter of time
before they come forward and expose him
for what he is he's not an idiot
he has known that this day was coming
and so he's had the incentive over the
last few years to cultivate a following
of people who distrust the media who
think that the media are out to get
Russell Brand and that they'll do
anything that they can to do that
and that's what he's been doing since me
too started that's the only way that he
avoids being canceled that's the only
way that this guy with the God complex
stays relevant is if he cultivates this
following of people who will disbelieve
anything the media put out about him
because they'd all trust the media he
has everything to gain from doing that
and that's exactly what he's done
successfully yeah I think it's really
funny that this is the conspiracy theory
that Liberals are going with because
Russell Brand was at Occupy Wall Street
when did me too start you know he's 17
2017. okay yeah Russell Brand has always
been been political he went to numerous
occupy events he's consistently spoke
spoken up about these things but I love
this conspiracy that 15 years ago he's
like you know one of these days they're
going to come after me for all the
horrible things I've done I better start
cultivating a bunch of conspiracy
theorists who will think that the the
media is lying about me
Mastermind he's like he knew he knew 15
years ago that me too was coming
apparently she didn't warn anybody so he
went to occupy to start spreading the
word and then people would like him and
then he felt like this is the craziest
thing honestly I wish it were true
because that would be even funnier in
some way but he had this crazy long-term
vision for like first I've got to make
some terrible choice in my life but I
will protect myself by cultivating a
podcast like it's crazy I'm being like
in 10 years I'll start a podcast that
cultivates anti-establishment fans but
for now I must go to Occupy Wall Street
to start them off yeah you saw him he's
got like the craziest whiteboard
timeline of all time machine he's got a
Megamind Dome correction it was up there
2006 that uh metoo was coined by Tarana
Burke an advocate for in uh for women in
New York yes 2017 that it went viral
nobody knew what it was until Russell
Brandon like 2013 started something
called the trues do you remember that
whereas like instead of the news it was
the truth he got woken up early on red
pill he's all about we don't need
Russell Brand's story to not trust the
media
don't trust the media it's like I watch
the news at this point and I'm looking
at when I watch Like CNN I can like tell
their federal agents I'm like yeah I
wonder when they graduated from there is
it because the Chiron says former CIA
director or even even the girl that's
trying to just be there like I'm like
yeah but but these these uh these uh
Intel uh officials and and analysts and
everything get jobs at the corporate
press and and the Chiron says like
former CIA and they're there in these
roles it's not even it's not it's not
even a joke it's just like yes how was
your mind control course when you're at
the FBI it's going great I'm doing it
right now you know what's messed up
about these allegations though is that
when they when you get when they get the
get you on this you can't defend
yourself you're now you're you're in an
investigation you can't say anything to
defend yourself so now they could just
drag your name through the mud for
however long it takes and this is what
you were talking about earlier like how
do we fix this because
now your whole Legacy is tarnished
because you can't say anything about
you know you gotta win a culture War
yeah because if you say no I didn't then
you're acknowledging the premise of the
accusation yeah your lawyer tells you
not to say nothing you know the culture
that's why I like that like he put on a
statement being like none of this is
true right like there are so many people
who try to like put their head in the
sand be like it's not happening or like
you know I'm so sorry that you guys feel
like maybe I did something wrong in the
past like just being like no none of
this is real is more interesting it's
also more true to character for Russell
Brand I think as much as you know a lot
of people in this room know already not
to trust the media when he went on Bill
Maher and I think it was in March that
clip him saying all these things you
know as many people who are like oh my
gosh good point there are just as many
people being like yes thank you for
saying this on a national platform like
they're pretending like he came up with
this idea of uh uniting people who don't
trust the media people who don't trust
the media find each other all the time
Gilmore I was trying to cut him off so
hard too he's like okay that's enough
right don't say it don't say bad things
about Pfizer oh what awful companies I
love that clip where it's like today's
broadcast is brought to you by Pfizer
brought to you buy Pfizer brought to you
by Pfizer it's like every single Media
company and that's the way it goes man
and that's why uh you know we
for the most part don't have a lot of
sponsors for this show we do on the
podcast audio side of things and it's
because like I don't want to be put in
these positions there's a reality that
someone might come to us and be like hey
you know we sell this product and then
we'll be like oh sounds totally cool
then we'll do ads and then we'll get
emails be like hey did you know this
product is actually bad because they do
these things to their employees and it's
like okay what do we do they've paid us
it's a conflict of interest do we drop
them that's like cancel culture how do
we investigate something like that it's
like oof that stuff's rough yeah I don't
want to tell people we're not going to
shout out their companies because we
have that fear though but there is the
the other side of predominantly why I
wouldn't want to go with a major
corporation is because like dude I
assume if you're at a certain size
you're probably just evil you know like
and any massive like Starbucks oh look I
like Starbucks right heavy they're one
of the only coffee shops with heavy
cream you want to get coffee and you're
walking down the city but I'm just
convinced they're evil oh yeah I think
they're poisoning everyone when you
start really looking into health uh be
be be very afraid of what you eat if
you're not eating all grass-fed Organic
Raw everything's got to be like
absolutely untainted it is Starbucks is
Tainted definitely you could taste it if
you really just stop and listen to your
body you could feel the poison what are
the ingredients
um it says the ingredients are brewed
Starbucks trademark coffee water coffee
reduced fat milk sugar cocoa pectin
that's it 15 of that company is owned by
Black Rock but the question is when it
says sugar is it high fructose corn
syrup or is it like cane sugar neither
white Sugar's bad does it say it once
this is a secret sugar but typically
they specify right yeah the secret that
you learn in the holistic natural
medicine world is when it says natural
flavors they are legally allowed to put
whatever they want under that yeah that
there's not regulations
raspberry flavored comes from Beaver ass
yeah or something like that don't trust
anything that says natural flavors
beaver anal glands they're it's called
um look it up you know what I actually
is it somewhere I think that's actually
true I don't
oh God it's just so disgusting to read
about it it hasn't even gotten to the
food part yet in food
um
flavor schnapps commonly yeah variety of
schnapps doesn't really say
what specific flavor it is
vanilla have you ever seen a beaver
swimming no I said vanilla underwater Oh
yeah you have vanilla they're like
awesome swimmers and I was fishing the
other day and it was just flying
that's awesome this is vanilla I thought
it was uh like raspberry says uh the FDA
regards because storm has natural
flavoring just in time for the holiday
cookie season we discovered that vanilla
flavoring your baked goods come from
anal excretions of beavers it was also
considered to be used in the cigarettes
to increase the the smell the flavor and
the odor wow little did you know have
you ever seen the videos with a pink
slime
when did you guys get invested in this
um I've been so I'm an athlete I've been
playing uh Sports my whole life but
lately I've been trying to biohack you
know I feel like I'm I'm in a place
where I want to see I want to see what I
can do I want to see what I'm capable of
is you know in in this in this body I
have so I've been working on bio hacking
I've been you know micronutrients uh
everything I put in my body at this
point is really thought out I wake up I
I do I do the sauna I cold plunge I whim
hop breathe I ground I do I do any form
of of biohacking for health and I want
to see I noticed the difference in my
life I noticed my focus I notice I play
sports at a higher level I notice a lot
of benefits of it so I've been really
doing that for the past year hard but my
whole life I've been involved in in you
know trying to eat right and I mean not
when I was 12 right when I'm 12 I'm
eating pizza and french fries that was
the turnaround for me when I learned you
know my mom I love her but she was
feeding us Frosted Flakes and all these
things when you look at this stuff when
you look up with frosted flakes or what
Doritos and what these these foods do to
you they kill us that's it they're
poisons they're chemicals they're
hazardous to our health it's it's it's
crazy that we consume this but we're
we're used to it and do you like
evangelize it to the rest of the band or
how does this work
yeah my wife's a naturopathic doctor
she's been a water pack doctor for like
10 years and when I'm home from tour
like she was doing all her schooling
online and uh so I was just soaking in
all the information so yeah I've known
about seed oils for like eight years
seed oils do you guys go into stem cells
and uh like stem cell therapy or NAD I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do I do NAD and I'm
gonna do stem cell therapy in January on
on my knee where are you going you go to
Tijuana CPI I'm gonna go to Mexico
I haven't picked that out yet but I'm
already going to Mexico City for
something else so I was gonna just that
go to Cellular performance states where
we went and it's uh Eddie Bravo shot him
out on Joe Rogan those guys are awesome
and it's I'm gonna go bro you you sit in
a chair looking at the ocean and there's
Dolphins like it's so I want to do it so
Rick would you like genetically alter
yourself to be healthier like like
straight up crispr Tech no nope it's got
to be from God or it's got to be for
something that that is natural I'm the
more the older I get the more I learn
everything that we need is on this Earth
to heal ourselves everything the Earth
heals us God has put every single thing
we need here to heal us if you don't
have a cold plunge you could you could
get a cold shower you could you could
stand out in the rain if you're in an
area like this right there's there's
ways to be re-energized the sun well
everything we need is here I heard a lot
about cold lunch a lot about putting
your head under so if you don't have a
full tank just get like a big bowl put
ice in it and then submerge your head
for like 20 seconds they say you should
take cold showers in the morning you
shouldn't take hot showers I never take
hot showers everything's cold yeah it's
like what is it it's hot at night and
cold in the morning or something like
that if you're gonna do it I just I just
feel I just jump in and get it as cold
as possible and I just I just let it dry
it's that first breath where it's like
oh but then afterwards you feel like I'd
energize let's jump to this next story
this is big news ladies and gentlemen
Marine Corps leader orders Safety Stand
Down of all aircraft after F-35
disappearance I want to give a shout out
to the lectern guy because he posted a
meme of himself carrying the missing
F-35 out of the capital building it was
a funny day for people making fun of
this well there was uh I have to find
his name but one of the congressmen
posted one of the milk cartons with the
missing so he's like if you find it call
the dod here's the story there was an
F-35 uh the pilot ejected it remained on
autopilot and no one knew where it went
and so everyone was very concerned that
it was flying around uh they found a
debris field I guess so it did crash
well but but now this is the crazy thing
that they say uh they're ordering the
Safety Stand Down apparently there have
been there have been a series of
failures there's been more than one
they say the Pentagon said in a
statement that the pause and operations
would allow units to discuss Aviation
safety matters and best practices during
a Safety Stand Down Aviation commanders
will lead discussions with their Marines
folks and fundamentals blah blah blah as
he just mentioned it was it was three
different incidents what was what was
the time periods like the past couple
weeks yeah I mean this is crazy man look
at this they said decision to stand down
comes into two deadly Marine Corps
crashes last month an F-18 pilot died
during a training flight near San Diego
and three marines died and more were
wounded when an osprey crashed off the
coast of Australia the Pentagon noted
the two previous accidents in its
statement Monday I'm sorry man I I mean
no disrespect I know you know these are
men and women in uniform they're losing
their lives in these instances but when
they lower the standards and they inject
the wokeness into our armed forces and
people of Merit don't want to be there
and people who probably shouldn't are
this is what you'll get and it's it's
not just in the in the military in the
Air Force or whatever in the Marines
it's going to be everywhere it's
possible that it is like what you're
saying is incompetence and that they
really have to shut down and make sure
these guys are trained or it could be
that our Machinery is getting hacked and
they are afraid that if they keep it up
and running that it's going to get
turned around on us
did you guys hear about the hacking that
just happened in Vegas like last week
let me tell you about the hacking in
Vegas it was everywhere it wasn't Vegas
it wasn't in Vegas this is crazy yeah
this like so first let me just slow down
say it because I'm gonna get excited on
this one Ian makes a really really good
point that we could be being attacked
and how do you check to know an osprey
Crush so it's easy for us to be like get
well but it could be that the system had
had a worm implanted in the Opera in the
operating system in the guidance system
and then it crashes and they're like it
looks like an accident now they order a
stand down I kind of feel like that's a
possibility but here's here's what's
crazy about Vegas
Caesar's entertainment got hacked they
paid the bill because they are morons I
think it was 40 million dollars
ransomware hit Caesar's Entertainment
Systems this is not just one Casino the
Caesar Caesar's entertainment is a is a
ton of different casinos like Arya MGM
got hit separate company and they said
we will not pay smart move however holy
crap in DC at the Nash at National
Harbor which is they clear National
Harbor is one of the highest grossing
casinos in the country my understanding
I could be wrong 600 million dollars
last year that's what I'm told and if
you wanted to play there everything was
Cash like the olden days
it's I mean I kind of I I should have
gone and checked it out because it
sounds crazy but what they were saying
what the guys were telling me is that
you'd go to a slot machine you could
only put cash in and when you print it
at a ticket they would come in hand pay
you because there was no machines to put
it anywhere that's what I'm talking
about there's no way in hell I'm gonna
settle for a USBC a central bank digital
currency are you crazy no one is going
to stand for that when the power goes
out can't do nothing the hell you expect
let Society run oh dude worse than that
man so with with Caesars paying the bill
I mean it's remarkable how stupid these
people are but they're probably thinking
like look it's 40 million dollars we
make billions every year just pay it
otherwise we could lose you know insert
amount of money yeah what they don't get
about this is that the ransomware didn't
go anywhere you paid the bill your
computer's turned back on well you still
gotta flash your entire system you still
got to rewind it to get rid of that
malware and you don't know where it is
they can do it again they'll do it again
and they will do it again so MGM said
we're not paying it probably because
they were like guys if we pay this we
lose the 40 million then they could come
right back a week later and do it to us
again what could also be any one of us
it could be all of our bank accounts it
just shows you that they're getting in
the money you know they're getting the
money off Caesars they're they're
they're fine this is an attack like what
you said and it was a an attack that led
to someone making it's actually Joe
Biden's ransomware so he could help pay
for the Ukrainian War yeah man I'm
surprised you have 35 didn't end up oh
we found it was Urban Ukraine yeah but
some people thought they turned to Cuba
that they just autopiloted its way over
to Cuba for the Chinese to take over and
study so this is this is a crazy reality
of where we're at I think it makes it
brings up a really good point we should
consider the the military implications
right I I think it's fair to point out
that the lowering of Standards I think
it's kind of an Occam's razor but it's
hard to know for sure what what is the
simpler solution that our armed forces
have been in a state of decay with
people retiring resigning and not
wanting to be involved anymore because
of the injection of wokeness those are
that's a true story yeah or is it
simpler to say we get attacked they're
ha cyber attacks are legit and real and
we are at war with Russia whether anyone
wants to admitted or not yeah and three
three crashes in a month could that be I
I feel like it sounds conspiratory I'll
say but we are in in war is it possible
that Russia is like let's start
attacking their infrastructure well and
Russia knows that we continuously miss
all of our our recruiting goals like
it's not a secret that we're not doing
well in terms of recruiting high quality
candidates we are open about the culture
that we are breeding the military I mean
videos of what was it one of the the
sailors like in uniform they spins and
he's in drag like these things go viral
all the time so I I don't think it's a
one or the other I think it's a
combination of both people know that we
are vulnerable right now look at these
wars sorry Trevor have you seen what
China's doing with their military
recruitment they're starting to train
little kids oh how old they have like
like straw figures with Japanese
Uniforms on them and these little kids
are stabbing them with like that makes
me think they're preparing for war in
the next 10 years A lot of people are
saying that a speculation just to get
like National uh to get these kids like
kind of brainwashed in the beginning
like they're not actually training them
but they want them to fight in 10 years
well they're preparing for it whether or
not they want it I don't know I don't
want it either I mean China does this
with everything right they're famous for
their gymnasts who get separated from
their their families at Young ages just
to train all the time to become the best
I mean it is about keeping up the
National Standard there they're having a
really big uh famine Lookout right now
because uh what's it the legion ping or
whatever he's he's like starting to talk
about world hunger is all of our or
world food production is all of our you
know responsibility and they're they're
saying that because of the droughts and
the uh the floods that their uh
production of food production is like
really really bad right now and then you
got to consider
what does a country do and they don't
have food for their people do they just
say yes we die or do they take food from
someone else oh yeah but they have a
pattern of letting you know China has
let 90 million people starve and die
before and have been family history with
them yeah it's in their history they're
not gonna admit it right like let's see
yeah it's not like they're gonna be like
oh please you end give us some extra
food they're just going to sacrifice
their people for it right think about
the military too you're you're a strong
soldier in the military you see what's
going on does this this does everything
that's happened in Ukraine if you were
to study everything that happened in
Ukraine and they were like you're
getting ready to okay now we got to send
American troops wherever you're going to
Ukraine what would you say you'd be like
pass right pass who would it get to it
would be down to people who probably
don't even know how to pull a gun out of
and we were already coming out of that
with Afghanistan right I mean we were in
the all of the conflict in the Middle
East for so long there were tons of
people who grew up feeling disintered
disenfranchised like right and then on
top of that there's a complete culture
of I I don't want to do this there's not
a culture of patriotism it's a good
thing you see it in some pockets of
society but overall we don't really have
any incentive to be in the military
other than the financial benefits which
for a lot of people it makes a huge
difference right being able to get on GI
Bill and have housing and stuff like
that but uh I think we are severely
disadvantaged so today I was about two
in the afternoon after I was reading
about this F-35 I was like I want to
join the military for the first time my
life and it wasn't to fight it was so
that we don't have to fight and it was
to protect and to serve as some sort of
intelligence aspect like I've been
thinking about drones getting hacked and
turned around on us for like seven years
is military not aware of that are they
not focused on that there's two there's
two trains of thought the first is that
the system is decaying and corrupt led
by morons and so good luck it's a
bureaucratic Nightmare and people don't
feel fulfilled because it's hard to move
around and do things properly without
playing some weird game the other
thought is
the actual US military is a well-oiled
machine run in secret through Black
Operations and you'll never know yeah
pick one maybe it's both a little bit of
both huh I meet some I made some strong
military guys but they all seem not
pumped about the direction of like we're
talking about the direction of the
military the the the the guys that I
meet are that are like that are like
ready to to go
I believe are now rocking with civilians
like they're they're more aware of with
us and our communities and uh and and
staying vigil on that side you know one
of those those are the type of guys that
just get accusations thrown against them
so they don't have to be dealt with one
day like oh this guy looks like he's
gonna start a revolution of some sorts
or they don't take the vaccine they get
kicked out yeah you're out of here yeah
that that was crazy which direction
generations of of military leadership
right there's still one to inherit these
positions we've got a strong leadership
I've met I've met a couple guys and I'm
sure to people listening and you guys
probably know some too that I met one
guy who was he was a captain and he was
just like I resigned he's like I'm out
and he said his intention was to run to
was to retire just go be in for his
whole career and then when they started
introducing critical race Theory stuff
he was like nope I'm out it's all you
that's what that was crossed my mind I
was like well if I joined the military
I'd get stuck in some bureaucracy and
have to follow orders that I don't agree
with and I don't know other than being
the president and trying to guide him
from the top I don't know how to help
and you're not going to have access to
those people the dude who's going to be
above you could be woke for all you know
and he's gonna be like oh this guy's a
troublemaker go put him in a box and
also our country's becoming I love our
country by the way I don't want to
insult in any way but our country is
becoming something less desired to fight
and risk your life for with the way it's
the direction is trending it's like
there was a time where where people
would would die for their country
certainly and people would go to war and
go to battle and people do anything for
their country but when you look at what
we're dealing with today in today's
climate with with just the state of the
country it doesn't look like something
that everyone's just jumping forward to
to put everything on the line for I'm
more focused I feel that way about my
community and my family and my friends
I'm I'm like gung-ho about protecting
that infrastructure of community and and
in churches and and people that are that
are in my everyday life you know I just
I think it would be hard to get
people to to risk their lives for this
state of this country homelessness
everything that's going on it's a shame
and what you're doing serves the
military because it protects and
stabilizes the local communities so that
they don't have to worry about coming in
to defend it you're there you're going
to protect it right but we we gotta
start thinking about protecting the
local communities I think I'm doing
everything local I'm getting out of this
I'm trying to get out of it you already
do it I'm trying to get out of the
Matrix as much as possible I'm trying to
not support any corporations I'm trying
to get everything in my life local I'm
trying to be more involved in my
community I'm trying to be more of a you
know I'd like to be more of a leader in
my community because in case something
happens you know we're going to need
each other this is a scary thing
people don't know their neighbors and so
what happens when a crisis happens what
happens when the roads get shut down and
I'm not let's let's not even talk about
the apocalypse let's say like sometimes
it rains let's say you you live in your
neighborhood those of you that are
listening how many of you know your
neighbors I'm sure a lot of you do
because this the people who listen to
this show are on the higher end of the
uh of like awareness bell curve or
whatever to call it but let's say you
live in a neighborhood when I lived in
uh you know when I lived in Chicago for
instance when I was a teenager when I
was into my early 20s and rented an
apartment with my my friends like you're
on the second floor of a house I didn't
know anybody who lived anywhere near me
what happens if the road gets gets shut
down is a major accident storm hits
massive blizzard nobody can drive
there's no in and out there's no grocery
store they can't get supplies to the
store who are you gonna ask for help you
even know your neighbors you need people
need to talk like talk to their
neighbors build community so that in the
event of a flood a fire hurricane you
name it you have a plan for what you do
in the event and United what happens
look I keep hearing and that this is
going to sound like a crazy conspiracy
theory but what's the only word you've
heard in the last six months two years
the word AI right AI I was gonna do
everything I know bands that are like
hey I wrote the song for me no I I know
everybody saw my AI what are you gonna
do the data AI shows up but you're
you're gay to your community and and
it's just got to make its rounds to to
collect tax Holdings like what are you
gonna do no no no no you don't think
that's ever gonna take your cbdc yeah
you're gonna have your Central Bank
digital currency and it's going to be
Zapped out of your account you don't got
to file taxes anymore don't worry
they're they're gonna do they're gonna
say are you tired of filing taxes it's a
pain in the butt isn't it how about this
with cbdc all automatically done for you
you're gonna think about it I mean the
thing is AI isn't going to do the thing
that we need Community to do right like
you have young children you're married
like if your wife had a medical
emergency in the middle of the night and
you had to take her to the hospital
hopefully your neighbor next door would
come over and sit with your kids right
like there are some things that we just
can't replace with technology and it's
really important to know the people
you're around we talk about it all the
time in terms of being proactive knowing
who your kids are involved with you're
doing business with things like that but
there are times that there's just no
substitute for the people around you Ian
uh you said you said that you sent me
that AI video oh did you we should play
a little bit of that I was just thinking
about it maybe we'll play it uh super
freaky we'll give it like a full segment
yeah that was sent to me by the
architect members on there or something
but this is like what was it like five
minutes or ten minutes how long was it
it was like three three to five three to
five minutes a fully AI generated video
it was AI voice too and no I think
someone did the voice I think it was
only the visuals or AI but I can't tell
whoever did the voice is a genius The
Voice could have easily have been AI
great actor but this is a this is like a
three minute video and we are after
watching this I'm like yeah okay we're a
year away from from bro
we're gonna pull up the AI you're gonna
type in the chat GPT or something and
you're gonna say
Rick generate me a music video of a song
by adelita's way and it will be perfect
the video will play it will be you guys
it will sound like you playing and
singing You'll watch it and say what is
this sounds like an easy way to cancel
anyone look what he said hi version of
you like let's say the worst things ever
and I gotta didn't say that I swear or
you can't cancel anybody anymore yeah
because everyone just says it's AI says
about Trump trump can come out back I
was AI look at the capabilities of what
the the there's a video of the
progression of even just a physical
robot and what they can do and when you
watch that video you will be like that's
what robots are doing nowadays they can
do front flips back flips land comp
they're they're so the the there's a
version of a robot out there right now
that's so Advanced that it's concerning
dude there's slight there's slime robots
have you seen them they're they're
amorphous they're like amoeba and
they're robotic they're like I don't
know if they're uh iron graphene I don't
know what they're made of exactly but
they can go around and through cracks
and stuff well they really they really
must be susceptible to a to ARS because
that seems to be the thing that they
want none of us to have they they
they're mounting scrap rifles onto these
these drone dogs have you seen the
videos right
scrap metal because I'm that drone dog's
gonna get blown away right I'm that's
the kind of stuff you got to be ready to
blow away I don't want to go to a Civil
War and hurt no people I don't think
that that the people we're dealing with
even are are brave enough to do that
they seem to kill from afar is by far
the most important thing we can possibly
do right now is build up our drone
defense systems be it robot dogs or
flying swarm drones hit them with a
couple bullets lasers fall out of the
sky well no no no no we should use them
he sang No and we need to learn how to
defend against them too that's coming
like whether it's robots dogs on the
ground or from the sky swarming you from
every angle we need to learn how to
defend again so this is the thing about
war right now it's mostly drones like
we're seeing in Ukraine and stuff and
yeah I think I think you make a good
point in that regard what we are missing
I think is microwave takedown techniques
jamming techniques now the problem is
it's erased an arms race they make more
resilient drones you make drone takedown
methods it's just it's going to be an
arms race you know uh an escalation of
the capabilities of these devices I
think people need to consider this too
and I want to save a lot of the AI stuff
we'll talk about this in the members
only but I warned about this 10 years
ago I was uh uh me and my guys my
friends we launched the first live
streaming aerial drone and we're we were
broadcasting from Occupy Wall Street
with it we got invited to a bunch of
like University and like government
panel stuff I was selecting like a test
location for where they would begin
setting up and devising regulations on
drones and I told these guys
you need to prepare for when they take
these things and they use them as
Weapons because if one of these things
gets launched from 50 miles away and
then sent full speed towards say New
York City what do you do and they they
don't even know and I'm like this kind
of stuff is as at your doorstep and I'm
and this is a terrifying thing but now
you're seeing it in Ukraine where they
have these videos where they're using
them as weapons of war so we definitely
need our cities to be proactive on this
stuff to prevent it I do think there's
probably really Simple Solutions we
should think about
the problem is what do you do when this
thing falls out of the sky so if you if
you do like infrared lasers on the top
of buildings to Target a drone that you
know an unknown drone or a vessel coming
into your city if you hit that thing to
stop it it falls it's gonna land
somewhere but you know I I don't I don't
have all the answers you got to pull it
towards where you want it to land but
you bro okay well let's save this for
the members only we'll get more serious
on the full AI because we'll play that
video too but I do want to jump to this
story because this is an existential
crisis we have that we need to address
lampedusa the migrant crisis nurse says
welcome everyone as Islands residents
complain they have to wait for care more
than 12 000 migrants have arrived on the
Italian island of lampedusa in the past
week putting the staff like Franco
galletto under serious strain
you may have seen the story there's an
island in Italy it is relatively close
to Tunisia it has 6550 or so residents
and there are now 12 000 migrants
economic migrants who have come in most
of them fighting age males
I'm sorry man look there's videos of
people saying up barricades there's a
video going viral of people fighting
that is not from this island
that was an older video but there is a
video going viral right now that I
haven't confirmed where it shows people
setting up barricades and the argument
is
look these migrants have started setting
up their own territorial zones
you get 12 000 people into your
community of six thousand your community
does not exist anymore it's over the
will of the people right democracy okay
well these people are here if you don't
believe in borders they're going to vote
for whatever they want I'll tell you
this they're gonna go take your stuff
they're going to come in they're going
to take your stuff they're going to
leave they're gonna go somewhere else
right and what's the number one thing
that that you know the people in charge
are trying to do
take away our opportunity take away our
ability to defend ourselves in in case
of any Invasion like this right when I
see someone like Gavin news from all his
pages is like we need to eliminate guns
and do this the other thing it's like
that that you can name 10 different
things that put us in a bad position if
we don't have guns this is another one
well I mean an invasion of another
if there's if the videos are true that
they're starting to seize territory
now you're getting into war and that's a
scary thought yeah someone referred to
the migrants that just came in today as
reinforcements yeah I mean this island
is effectively occupied by migrants from
Northern Africa that that's what this is
I mean the interior minister of France
went there today and he said you know we
should help Italy we should keep our
borders open and it's very important you
know the thing is when you get to Italy
it's a pathway into the EU but the EU
says Italy you have to process all the
Asylum Seekers and so the presuming that
all the migrants there are going to
apply for Asylum which I just think
statistically is not going to happen and
so this becomes an incredible problem
that communities are having to listen
you were talking about wanting to do
things locally these 6 000 people are
now having to accommodate 12 000 people
possible that doesn't it's not gonna
happen it's not just that it's that if
we're supposed to you see what AOC was
saying in New York when she said
everyone's screaming at her saying get
these illegal immigrants out of our city
their resources are strained and she
says we're going to give them work
rights we're going to give them more of
our tax resources and we're going to
give them a special protected status
she's yelling over the people who are
screaming at her to stop she does not
care
so now think about what's going on with
with the EU this problem's been
happening for for a decade plus it got
really really bad several years ago and
it's not being abated
if they follow the course they have in
many other countries what's going to
happen is the people who are there which
be given special rights
what happens when you have a piece of
land with 12 000 people
who are not allowed to vote and there
are six thousand five hundred people who
do vote eventually the 12 000 people say
there's more of us than there are of you
and we now get the right to vote so what
is what will likely happen in these
circumstances is that I'm sorry your
laws are only meaningful so long as they
can be enforced your borders are only
meaningful so long as they can be
enforced twelve thousand people show up
by all means your law still exists for
you not for them they don't know your
laws and they don't care and if they
want to set up barricades and take
territory they'll just do it
people need to understand that when it
comes to law it's just what's in your
brain right if you if if you go to a if
you're like from West Virginia go to
Ohio Law's different
you might just mean you didn't even know
was illegal let's say Pennsylvania
you're allowed to you're allowed to
carry a gun in Pennsylvania not in New
Jersey you didn't know that well you
went somewhere else the laws were
different so what what this what this is
is what that woman who went to New
Jersey and had a gun and didn't know was
illegal and got arrested she did not
know the law of this other place now
what happens if 10 000 people cross into
New Jersey is that one cop gonna be able
to stop anybody your law only applies to
you who know it and follow it and I mean
to add on top of this most people don't
even know when new laws get passed
anyway especially when they ban guns
because it's like how are you supposed
to follow all that stuff they expect you
to be a good app it doesn't but yes but
my point here is this if 12 000 people
come into La producer do you think these
12 000 people know what the laws are do
you think do they care probably evil too
some probably will just try to take
what's theirs or take what they want or
you you know you're going to deal with a
lot of hostility there if 12 000 people
that don't have much are in a place that
has a lot of resources it doesn't you
know doesn't the EU already sell
subsidize the residences to house
immigrants so I mean we already know the
first thing that they're going to do
they're going to start making these
Locals House these people in their homes
yeah the expectation is that you got to
put four each house has to you know we
have double the uh people in our our
country now so you gotta put four people
in the East house and if you read all
the mainstream media articles that came
out about it today they all say but what
about the Tunisia deal and this was the
idea of the UN president uh Von laterson
I can never say her name but she and uh
the prime minister of Italy were working
on a deal with Tunisia because Tunisia
is the biggest Gateway for all of this I
mean this is where Smugglers
headquarters people in who are displaced
within Africa and know to go to Tunisia
and then potentially get into Italy
there and they were going to sit offer
them tunisia's economy as in shambles
and they're saying we'll give you a lot
of money to stop these boats from coming
over but we know I mean we talked about
this that that ultimate means that
Tunisia is like well when we need more
money we'll just let the migration go
back up the the deal hasn't been
brokered it getting stopped installed in
Brussels But ultimately this is a
terrible system it's similar to having
uh malware in your Casino thing where
you can say give me money okay I fixed
the problem just kidding it's not I want
money again like this system is broken
and we know it and the best that they
can do is to say please we'll give you
money to stop the boat well it didn't
work for New York right no he was saying
bring all the immigrants in and then now
we're gonna we're gonna subsidize you to
to house them and now he's saying I
don't see an end to this he said New
York is a sanctuary City and then
started busting migrants to suburbs of
New York and Upstate New York he said
this is everyone else's problem 110 000
migrants have come through New York in
the last year and at any given time the
state New York City is carrying between
for between 50 and 60 000 migrants
you've got to be somewhere and now
they're kicking out veterans out of
hotels to you know put the migrants in
and New York's already just in disrepair
there's the videos of the rats running
around that's awesome is this where the
sidewalks crumbling and you can see like
this Casey neistat posted this crazy
video and I'm like how did he get this
video he sees the sidewalk is is
crumpled and he he pushes into it and it
just Falls straight down and he sticks
his camera into the underground like
piping and everything and he was like
the sidewalks are scary in New York's
like well it's only going to get worse
brother dude thinking about this intense
over popular this migration a thousand
years ago if you have 20 000 people
arrive on your island of 6 000 people
you fight you you pull out your weapons
and defend your Island so they don't War
yes of course it would be an active but
the difference now I'm told to do that
the difference now is we have telephones
we have Internet we know that they're
not there to kill that's not I mean
obviously they didn't come they would
have been doing it if that was the
that's not the it doesn't seem like it
but we need to understand the history of
what happens when you let rapid
migration encroach on people's territory
if we don't accept and acknowledge what
has happened in the past it is very
likely that it will happen again in the
future but we can prevent it if we start
working on it now what's happening right
now is this is this is this is the
challenge nobody wants anybody to die so
you have these people on boats and and
the question is
what do you do turn the boat I think you
turn turn the boats back around it's
simple you say hey go back whatever not
we can't handle this but there's the the
the the the challenge now of they they
will Beach these boats We Can't Stop all
of them I mean it's it's Italy so don't
I shouldn't say we but the people there
can't stop all of them what do you do we
don't want anybody getting hurt the
problem is you've had these videos
especially in the southern border of
Mexico where they're smashing through
the barriers and fighting with the
border border guards and so the argument
is because they don't have guns of
violent incursion into Sovereign
territory by another group of people is
like just let it happen that's insane to
me but I'm not gonna pretend to have the
answers because like like I said nobody
wants the violence to break out nobody
wants violence to break out but I fear
this will make it inevitable because the
people who are there on the island are
going to need food they're going to need
shelter and they're not getting it
there's 12 000 of them you're gonna
probably see attacks on the locals
you're going to see people get their
property taken from them and the people
who are there are going to start
fighting violence is inevitable when
people violence is inevitable when
people get desperate and they don't have
resources it's it's an inevitable
unfortunately it's great to be like I I
love love and peace I mean I promote it
every single night on tour it's the
first thing that I want to promote but
violence is inevitable when when you
have people that are desperate and they
need to survive themselves right 12 000
people on an island they need to survive
I think I think the issue here some
people may be a bit more conspiratorial
I think it's more so that they just
don't care the the government of Italy
they're just like look I'm overwhelmed I
can't deal with this I know Georgia
Malone we don't care they went down
there this is from the BBC yes yesterday
Georgia Maloney went to the island she's
the Prime Minister send these people
back I know she's hardcore I mean and
that was what she campaigned on she
campaigned on an I will stop illegal
immigration platform so this is a big
test for her uh her government in
particular one I one of the things I
think the challenges she faces and it
reminds me a lot of what's going on in
Texas with the floating barrier is you
know there have been times where she has
been like I'm gonna deploy a naval
blockade so people can't come we'll turn
the boats back you know you can't come
here uh Florida has a policy where you
you can't take a boat from Haiti to get
here they will turn the boat back you it
doesn't count basically uh in Texas uh
Greg Abbott's in big trouble because he
put up this thousand foot orange buoy uh
barrier in the Rio Grande and initially
the doj said you have to take down we're
going to sue you because it's inhumane
yeah this is bad we should we shouldn't
stop people from swimming and his
response was you're the you're saying
it's inhumane because the swim is
dangerous so therefore the deterrent is
a good thing because then people don't
attempt it right and they change their
mind they said actually no know you
needed like the Army Corps of Engineers
to design this raft and really you
violated a congressional law I mean
they'll twist whatever they want to
ultimately get the effect of allowing
illegal immigration to continue to the
detriments of the communities that are
having to uh accommodate these people
and having to provide the resources that
they themselves probably don't have this
makes me think of in lampedusa this is
like if you play Civilization there's a
technique in that called a cultural you
can flip a city to your side with
cultural pressure and now I'm wondering
if that's actually in the game what
you're not seeing is the the migration
that's happening but it's like land
produces closer to Tunisia than it is to
Italy in the in the game this is more
akin to just attacking the city so in
but it's with unarmed civilians that's
why it's not really there's no well so
so in Civilization I don't know about
the later civilizations but in earlier
games I know this for sure I don't know
if I've played the later ones enough if
you send units into enemy borders and
fortify them you take that land and it's
a declaration of War so sending even
non-military into their country unless
you have open borders policy yeah but
then but then they all come in and then
they all surround the city and they
don't attack the city they just start
taking the land and then it results in
in work question the cultural thing is
more about the people in the city like
your way of life better and vote to join
you but if the people in the city are my
my people in your city then of course
they're gonna like my way is better than
yours but anyway I don't know you're
probably right did you guys know
um
all right never mind you got to put
yourself in the shoes of of the people
that it's happening to like imagine
you're sitting in your neighborhood but
you're gay and your gate opens up and
twice as many people are about to enter
your gate that live in your gate what do
you what do you do if you're the one
that's dealing with that it's so easy
for us to be halfway across the world
and think about that happening right but
it's starting to happen in New York City
it's starting to happen the biggest
Excursion I think I've uh I have the
Tweet right here let's pull this story
up bill malugan says breaking one of the
largest mass illegal Crossings we have
ever seen took place in Eagle Pass Texas
this morning border patrol sources
telling us over 2 200 people crossed
since midnight it happened right next to
the Port of Entry as illegal immigrants
continue to ignore the Biden admin
messaging of do not come and do not fear
the promised consequences of Crossing
illegally videos from Source in Mexico
and our Fox drone team I mean look at
these videos
this is Bonkers you've got people in New
York screaming at the politicians saying
stop this and it's only getting worse
what's the solution do we do we have to
set up we got to build a wall gotta
build a big beautiful wall from C to
shark or expand you know you the the US
is beautiful there's a lot of open land
in the U.S if the government wants to be
so a part of this they should take some
of the funding we're given billions of
dollars to to Ukraine no one knows where
the money's going take take two billion
dollars and go in that area in New York
where there was nothing and build them a
city or something I don't know
I'm sorry I'm sorry take the two billion
dollars get a bunch of buses that are
very nice and very comfortable and bring
them back on it and we send them back
home we send them back yeah the
challenge with deportation is that if
they're not Mexican citizens we can't go
to Mexico and be like we're sending
these people to your country within
reason so they end up getting flown back
to Guatemala or Honduras or wherever
they may be from many of these people
not a lot I'm saying uh I'm not saying
majority but a lot of them are coming
from South America and even Africa
they'll fly from Africa to Brazil and
then Trek all the way up to Southern
border where they know they can just
walk in here but them but Venezuelans
coming illegally through Mexico into the
U.S and is kind of like if Chris gave
you a Dr Pepper and you spilled it on me
I can't blame Chris because you're the
one that spills like Mexico is the one
that's letting them across the border
yeah so of course yeah hell yeah we can
send them back to Mexico I'm just saying
like
there are certain circumstances where we
go to Mexico and it's like hey we have a
bunch of these citizens that are not our
citizens you can't send them here it's
like it's of course like a finger trap
they want it it's like if it was easy it
would have been solved already we got it
we gotta how about this I think it's a
good point take all that money that went
to Ukraine and just spend it on
transportation for these people back to
their homes and securing the border and
stopping this because we can't sustain
this economically when when these people
are screaming at AOC like get these
people out it's because they're saying
we're cutting services we're cutting
police we're cutting you know your tax
benefits to fund these other people who
had just arrived people are like this is
insane I've been paying into the system
and now it's being taken from me by
these strangers who are coming in and
effectively stealing from us they should
just say you are not welcome to just
illegally enter all immigrants are
welcome in the United States but you got
to do it legally we could also maybe
instead of investing in slave labor in
China maybe start building factories in
these Central American South American
countries that are more the more that
our neighbors are also disagree we
should build factors in the United
States for Americans yeah I mean that's
that's definitely yeah the first thing
to do but maybe help these other
countries that are to the south of us
maybe have a better economy so they
don't want to come here we we already
spend the money in China might as well
get closer to our home it's kind of an
interesting argument like would it be
better to make it in at least in North
America or at least in this in South
America
and potentially alleviate our
immigration be good for the climate too
you know not as long as ship rides right
for the cargo I mean I ultimately
manufacturing jobs should come back to
yes but it's not a bad point like it is
it is we are willing to ship
manufacturing somewhere else but we're
saying oh these people are fleeing
economic and political turmoil yet we
are not adjusting anything we're doing
yeah my number one option is bringing
back manufacturing back to the United
States but I mean that's not happening
either so why is AOC so confident in
just telling New Yorkers how it is like
this why is she just out there like
they're all yelling at her and she's sat
there like yeah she's not listening we
don't care anybody she's just she's just
not listen with none of the people of
the commuter saying and she's why does
she feel that comfortable she could just
go in there and no one's gonna do
nothing
because nobody can vote her out so she
doesn't so she's gonna win her primary
because she she got like 14 000 votes
she gets a primary so she doesn't care
what one protest thinks because the
average person is not voting and that's
why people need to go out man I'm
telling you I think AOC could easily
lose her District especially over this
but people have to go there and just
start spreading the word informing
people because what happens is the
average person who votes in the primary
which effectively gets her elected the
average person who votes in the in the
Congressional elections they just vote
for Democrats they don't care who it is
AOC knows that's got to stop the only
people screaming and people pay
attention guess what you're few and far
between so she's thinking to herself I
can say whatever I want no it doesn't
matter Nancy Pelosi said she held up a
glass of water and said
people will vote for a glass of water if
you put a d on it in Meyer aoc's
District they know it they know that
this note this is what Republicans need
to do Republicans need to invest a
stupid amount of money in in her
District
that's it like they're doing in Texas
the the Democrats are doing that in
Texas to try to really get as much
influence they can there but it's just I
don't know looking at the parties it
just gets confusing because it's half a
unit party the Republican party is
pretty weak right it's it's the the the
the the Democrats come off very evil to
me right now there's a lot of things
that I'm seeing that I'm like they're
evil man I got a Super Chat like I was
like I also want to join the military
but I can't with Joe I can't I won't
Joan Joe Biden's military that's like
that's the evil yeah yeah but it's not
even that I mean it was Millie you know
I mean like even even if uh uh Trump
gets reelected is he going to clean
house and bring in better leadership he
has to if he doesn't I'm gonna be
suspicious to him I mean we're hoping he
does but he did it the first time and
that's why I am suspicious of him
because he didn't do it before so so the
general idea right now is Trump is your
best bet it doesn't mean it's a good bet
I should say it's it's your best bet
it's a good bet in that sense it doesn't
mean you're going to get what you want
he's a people pleaser he's like do you
see him talking about abortion and how
he's gonna make a deal with the
Democrats and he's like I'm Gonna Make a
Deal that Everyone likes about abortion
15 weeks nah it's like dude stop trying
to make everybody happy man that's not
it didn't work the first time you can't
just you can't just be an Entertainer if
you want to be in politics he got
clowned pretty hard by the coveted team
too the fauci and the Burks they they
just ran him you know that was tough for
me I just want anybody to come in at
that that stops the unjust that we're
seeing in the direction of culture and
society that we're seeing I think it's
it's getting pretty ugly and it needs to
be nipped in the butt and that's why I
just I just keep on putting my faith in
God and trying to be closer in my
community because I know that's what I
can do as my part this this is the most
important thing that people can do right
now because a lot of these problems that
we Face are daunting and a lot of people
want Simple Solutions like if I vote for
Trump trump does the job you know
whatever Trump is a good thing to do
spreading the word first and foremost is
more important because for every person
you convince to vote for and it's not
necessarily Trump it's for somebody
who's actually going to uphold our
values and trying keep Americans safe
and and better our economy and better
the world
convincing people to vote better
multiplies your vote for everyone you
convince but the most important thing is
always going to be I mean first let's go
in the hierarchy the least one of the
least important things in terms of
fixing all the problems is going to be
just voting for the President right
because you gotta more important than
that convince other people to vote for a
good president more important than that
convince people to vote for good members
of Congress more important than that
convince people to vote locally for your
State Rep state senator city council you
name it that's the stuff that is impact
on your city if everybody got everyone
to vote for good candidates at the local
level it starts to fix things from the
ground up then the next important thing
after all the Voting is said and done is
you got to succeed take care of your
family find a good job be physically
physically well stop eating the garbage
start exercising you know what I was
thinking as I was playing I'm playing
Baldur's Gate three I love this game and
it's such a popular game it's so big and
I'm thinking to myself how many people
are playing this game right now and
they're not upping their own stats when
you play games like this you level up
you get exp appearance points you level
up now your character is stronger
unlocking new abilities and I'm like how
many people play this game and love that
idea but don't do it for themselves that
that I'm like that's to be the training
program right that's the solutions man
you're offering Solutions this is what
you do you want a training program
someone and I'm sure this exists already
a personal trainer should create the RPG
training program where you get you you
level up and then they track your stats
and then they show you your your your
your your avatar or whatever it's
addicting treat it like a video game
where you're actually breaking barriers
and then it can be like in order to get
like I mean like uh uh martial arts
belts is kind of like this yep you level
up you get the next level you want to
attain that you want to get I think
that's how you gotta approach it dude if
you could get crypto for that and it
measures your Biometrics you like held
the handles and it's like you've gained
two percent body fat and they put like a
dollar ninety in your bank account
whenever you're horny your wife gets a
little heart singing wait wait wait wait
hey this is an idea hey this is an idea
that might get you in trouble Ian it's
probably already in development right
now
that generates cryptocurrency when
you're when you're it's gonna like so
you got these apps like I'm wearing this
watch and it tracks vitals and stats and
stuff like that so once you reach a
certain degree of like health and stress
and it goes down you're earning more
crypto per day the more healthy you are
like lower resting heart rate less
stress the more crypto it generates
yeah you just gotta make sure the code
is free and that you're controlling
because they're going to be sending all
that data some centralized debt ideally
they won't be but it's likely that if
you just grab some random app it's gonna
be sending marriages right you could be
like look babe my vitals are saying that
we haven't made love in four days
are proven that I need some imagine if
you made a video game that like earned
me some money when you when you defeat a
bad guy and it drops a few gold pieces
you get bonus multipliers based on your
personal physical health and like things
if you could somehow
um figure out like learning if you get
paid to learn like you go down and you
you're looking at the grass and you can
somehow discern like what kind of plant
that is uh I don't know that's
complicated long term but we can we can
actually like if you're playing a game
like Starfield or Baldur's Gate or
whatever No One's Gonna do this because
there's no money in investing in it it's
just a social good that no one's going
to want to do but imagine it's like oh
you get 1.1 times your experience points
if you're if you're at average Health
Fitness if you're above average you get
1.2 times and if you're unhealthy you
get minus one yeah rested XP again so
it's like a way to encourage people this
is this is the problem right now as the
United States is basically just this
gluttonous state of the seven I
shouldn't even say gluttonous I should
it's all the seven deadly sins people
are not taking care of themselves
they're not planning for for uh long
term they're not planning their families
they're not up bettering their their
bodies they're just chasing after those
dopamine hits and it's resulting in
decay
this would be a perfect opportunity for
like a really good health insurance
company
but they're all in bed with big Pharma
so they'd actually want to do that they
do this stuff like insurance companies
already do this where it's like if you
submit your health data they'll lower
your rates and things like that sounds
like a like well
it's kind of scary if you think about it
but I don't know man is it is it is it
is it that bad the challenge is what are
they doing with your data that may be
nefarious because there's going to be
corrupt people there but the idea that
you get to pay less because you take
care of yourself I think is a good thing
yeah or they pay you in crypto because
you save them money
I like the insurance incentivization
except that if they are like did you not
get vaccinated for some random thing we
think you should be then maybe it will
make you pay more for your insurance
this year yeah there's ambiguity and
what they Define as being healthy or
making good choices they could stop
making prices up at the hospital take
your kid in for a fever yeah Motrin will
do it two thousand four hundred and
twenty two dollars you're like that's a
made-up number two thousand four hundred
dollars for one night in the emergency
every woman I know who has given birth
in a hospital they say like they'll get
your bill you have to go back and ask
for an itemized Bill and then the number
drops it's like when you ask them
specifically what you're paying for
they're like oh just kidding
Let's jump to this story which is a hard
segue of a relatively silly story Senate
Majority Leader Chuck Schumer quietly
ditches dress code to cater for
Pennsylvania Democrat John fetterman and
his shorts and hoodies
this is just I mean like dude come on
man you want to wear you want to wear a
hoodie with Jim with jogging shorts that
I do not feel is appropriate however I
don't necessarily I mean this is
it is silly it looks like he got lost
and wandered in there right and so my
issue is this
first I agree with everybody when
they're like
don't change the rules for one dude it's
like yeah okay there is no formal dress
code it doesn't exist it's basically
just who's ever the the Senate leader
just determines if you're into Quorum or
whatever but they typically require
coats and ties I disagree with that I
also disagree with fetterman wearing gym
short jogging shorts and hoodies that's
silly but I I do think we shouldn't have
we we shouldn't demand this like Elite
decorum of suit wearing and special
dresses and all that stuff so my
attitude is
um
you should be dressed appropriately
meaning the the dress code should be
something like uh you have to wear pants
you have to wear shoes you have to wear
a shirt you could you can be removed if
you are determined to be like uh unkempt
or something like that but I don't agree
overall with the uh the standard dress
code people expect you know suit wearing
stuff and so the important thing to
consider is we kick the segment off
Donald Trump ate a well done steak with
ketchup it was a 30-day dry aged steak
at a fancy restaurant and he said how do
you want it says well done with ketchup
and the media mocked and insulted him
for it but Trump is smart he laid the
Trap when the media came out and started
insulting Trump for for eating a steak
well done with ketchup a lot of poor
people in this country eat their steaks
well done with ketchup they can't afford
the good fancy 30-day dry aged steaks
they want something that just tastes
good and they slap some ketchup on it
and that's that's for some people not
everybody you know there are poor people
who understand the Finer Things in life
and know how to make a good steak I'm
not saying that's not true but right now
the the Democrats trying to layers
they're trying to use fetterman as the
Everyman a guy who's just wearing Odeon
shorts it's a regular working probably
not his real outfit that's what I was
thinking right so calculated he probably
goes home off camera and puts a suit on
and sits in it he probably sits in a
suit in his living room and goes I wish
I could just dress like everyone else in
my they're probably like no John you're
putting on this you're putting on the
hoodie and you're putting on the shorts
that's just get on camera yeah but I
think you have I think in all
seriousness you're probably right to a
certain degree he goes home he doesn't
wear that I bet he wears is just like
jeans and a t-shirt normal clothes and
then he puts on the hoodie and shorts
for a Persona and they want you to
insult him for it because they're hoping
you insult Working Class People in PA
I'm not saying every working class
person in PA wears this but they were I
was seeing a lot of people post on
Twitter saying like hey man a lot of us
up here in Western PA we dress similarly
they have all our data and they did a
poll they have all our data they're
looking they're like hoodie and shorts
and he campaigned in the hoodie too I
mean this has been a consistent thing
for him uh I don't personally think that
there's anything wrong with having
different standards of dress and having
some places where it's more formal and
whatever else and again that might be
like the culture I grew up in right like
I went to I grew up going to church and
everyone wore a coat and tie like I'm
comfortable with it I can understand
where it maybe doesn't function as
mandatory like does it make a difference
if your congressman is wearing a tie I
don't know in this case with fetterman I
feel like they're trying to act like
whatever he does is normal because he's
not okay and I think in that way it's
some somewhat insulting to his
constituents right to say that oh well
he's just trying to relate to you
because he also wears a hoodie to work
like no he gets special exceptions
because he has never seemed to really
recover from the stroke he had yes but
most people don't watch the news they
don't pay attention they hear things in
passing that's why CNN does stuff like
despite there being no evidence of a
crime they're they're trying to impeach
Joe Biden which is just not sure there's
tons of evidence of a crime it should be
determined by a jury by first by
Congress in the Senate then by a jury
whether that was Criminal but that's
that
that's the setup I suppose but fetterman
runs one of the most corrupt states in
the whole entire country and all we talk
about is his hoodie and his pain his
someone in his office does run one of
the most corrupt States I'm not sure
it's him yeah I agree I think yeah he
he's definitely you know had health
health problems but Pennsylvania is is
very corrupt I mean I I grew up in
Pennsylvania and it's
it's we we should be talking about the
job he's doing too well I mean I love
this conspiracy theory that they swapped
him out with a body double yeah I think
is Alex Stein promoting that one
probably I don't know he loves
conspiracy theories but uh I don't
people because fetterman shaved and he
had a mustache though it's a different
guy and it's like oh come on it's not a
different guy his nose has the same
shape and everything and his ears are
the same and they're like no his ears
are bigger in one photo it's like dude
it's a wide angle versus a long very
unique guy yeah I know right there was
one where like they couldn't see the
tattoo on his arm so they're saying like
oh it's gone so it must be someone else
people just can't believe he won people
can't believe like wow that's the that's
that's the guy this is the issue about
people not paying attention to the news
that they can just run a headline insert
something nonsensical and people just
believe it so when it comes to fetterman
the average person doesn't hear him talk
the average person does not know or care
they see a picture of a dude who's
supposed to look like a regular
working-class guy he's he's not and then
when the media attacks him all they know
is like they're attacking John why what
did he do he's like a regular dude and
it's like you're like a stroke on camera
this is happening now they're having
like Strokes on camera and then be like
it wasn't a stroke it's like they
translate for him I saw that it was a
stroke how many times can we see
something with our own eyes and then get
reported that it was not what we saw
that's the point see you watched the
video 90 of people won't yeah so then
what happens is fetterman is sitting in
Senate in in the Senate and he goes why
course
gasoline
it's too much
why
huh and then the the media will then
write in a paragraph John fetterman gave
a passionate and exasperated plea to
lower the price of gas and reduce the
amount of cars on the highway they don't
they won't actually quote what he said
they'll just create an interpretation
then someone will see a picture of John
fetterman going like this like hmm and
then it'll say that and they'll be like
wow and they won't realize that he
didn't actually say anything English I'm
voting for this guy his fingers up well
I mean I'm passionate to be fair Michael
malice said this is this is the guy to
vote for okay buying a hoodie I'm
booting no but you want more uh uh in
incapable individuals in Congress you
want to hold I disagree because who's
Staffing them right like if he's a
puppet someone's someone's maneuver not
he's not a puppet it's that he is in
there confused and bewildered and his
office is in disarray and so if every
member of Congress in the Senate whereas
disheveled and disoriented as fetterman
then the government would just be
stuck well they already are stuck what
happened what do we get the report out
uh oh we seem to misplace 176 trillion
dollars you guys seen it anywhere like
what happened really there was hundreds
of millions of dollars we just lost a
100 million dollar jet we lost 100
million dollars but there's 20 billion
today I think they lost they did like an
audit of the Pentagon they did something
right and they they found a crazy amount
of missing money and I was like you
should check Ukraine it could be there
is there a website where you can see how
much money was lost today by the US
government no but there should somebody
make that website that'd be nice yeah we
should look at the offshore accounts so
it might have been lost to those
I want to address this about the uniform
uh because Kane Abel super chatted
saying that wearing a suit and ties
about respect for the office and and
those and those that represent it's not
about a leadish behavior how many suits
do you own how many suits do you own one
one suit yep how many suits do you own
one how many Ian they're out like seven
jackets how many suits do you own no I
don't know I have one suit one suit it's
a disco suit and I should wear it
they're very old and they don't fit very
well anymore I don't own any Suits now
you have one one if you're going to be
in session where you have to be wearing
a suit every day one's not gonna cut it
you're gonna need a couple more right
how much that suit cost it was expensive
yeah too much it's a good one it's a
good one uh but but they have affordable
suits for people who you don't want to
break the bank uh I would also assume
the average person probably if you
couldn't afford if you're living Patriot
to paycheck you're probably gonna have
to go to a thrift store to buy a suit
I'm not saying suits the hardest things
in the world to get I just don't like
the idea of some arbitrary cultural
standard of what you must now own to
represent Working Class People or anyone
in this country suits
in my view are this this social custom
of I am wearing a thing because we have
deemed this to be the thing you have to
wear in this setting it doesn't mean
anything to me I would rather see a dude
in in his work overalls with grease on
his hands in the Senate building saying
I got off work 20 minutes ago and I'm
not going to drive an hour back and
forth just so that I can put on a suit
for you this is what real working class
Americans look like instead we get
clammy hands frail dainty
multi-millionaires doing insider trading
wearing their suits and demanding here's
the worst part here's what what I hate
about this okay fine you want to make an
argument everyone's got to dress up
that's fine the problem is this my
compromise is you want a dress code for
fetterman they have to pay for it you
can't mandate someone but then what
about what about visitors what about
people who want to testify you want to
go and testify we have a dress code you
can't come in unless you're wearing a
suit the expectation that every person
in this country is going to have access
to these things now again I will stress
I'm not saying it's the hardest thing in
the world to get a suit but I just don't
like the idea that there could be a
circumstance where we want a farmer to
testify and he says look man I'm in the
field 16 hours a day I ain't got no time
to go out and get get a tailor fit suit
or find a suit maybe I can borrow one
but if they want to come in and they
want to show what it actually is like to
be the person who is the foundation of
this country producing the things that
make this country good then or make this
country function then I think it's fine
to say okay maybe you shouldn't have
grease on your hands wash your hands in
the bathroom clear that off but if
you're going to show up showing the
American people this is what it looks
like when you work for this country I
find that acceptable and I don't like
that they're like you can't come into
our Elite chamber because you represent
this country so you have to wear the
clothes we determine you can wear well
and I
larger cultural change I mean we used to
be a more formal Society men used to
wear hats like there were all kinds of
things that we used to do that still
cling on some parts of society and don't
exist everywhere right like a hundred
years ago hoodies didn't exist people
still got dressed they wore something
else I mean there was a time when there
was an expectation of dress code that
was just different and maybe it's good
that our culture has changed but I don't
think that like it has to be elite I
think you're right that people should be
able to come shouldn't be excluded
especially if it's going to affect their
daily lives because they don't have a
suit I got no problem with you have to
wear pants you have to wear shoes you
have to wear a shirt and you have to be
clean I can totally understand all those
things there's questions of hygiene and
I do respect to a great degree the idea
of professionalism I don't respect the
idea of the arbitrary suit as the symbol
of what it is to be professional because
I view a working class American in his
maybe it's a mechanic and he's wearing a
jumpsuit that to me is more indicative
of someone who works for this country
than these I'm going to refrain from
cussing and insulting these pieces of
trash these corporate funded sellouts
who don't actually represent you and
your value use and sell your values out
to the highest bidder what would you
think very little respect for these
people and to be like it's the clothing
they wear that shows professionalism uh
that I'm sorry dude how about this every
one of these people has to wear the
outfit that is D that is the average
worker's clothing in the state they come
from they sold us out to the max it
feels that way right now right now today
I feel like we've been sold out to the
max by the people that are in charge I
feel like it's I feel that way
personally I'm like man they every time
they get together they don't make the
right decision for the civilians and the
people every single time and just like
what you're saying you're having a hard
time even not saying bad things about
those you want to lose your mind you
want to be like these but it's a bright
attitude none of this is where we are
right now none of these people are an
actual representation of the people in
their state maybe maybe a couple and I
want to say no I I I shouldn't be
absolute because there's a handful of
people I do like that are in Congress in
the Senate but I'm just I'll say it
again the idea that they determine that
what they wear is proper respect and
what the average working-class American
wears is disrespectful I do not like
that idea again fetterman should not be
wearing jogging shorts that that I agree
is no Hammer pants yeah look no I mean
pants whatever man just wear pants be
clean wear a shirt and pants what about
shorts I have no promising you can't
have shorts on you got to wear pants
what about this shirt
something like that you do or don't no
problems because people will wear more
scandalous and Wilder shirts to stand
out in Congress button it up don't show
your chest or whatever and that's the
thing about like I think it's fine if
they're saying he's got to wear pants at
the very least like shorts are not
acceptable I'm totally about color like
if they don't care color's fine you
think they kick Sam Smith out for having
that shirt of that little baby child
yeah lollipop no they would that's not
open arms they would welcome him in
right oh Sam I love your shirt on the
floor I just you know I gotta be honest
I really don't like suits I don't like
ties neckties our liability it's a choke
Hazard that's the first thing I thought
of when we were talking about suits is
your choke has I can't stand I don't
wear neckties I'll wear suit jackets
happily because they keep me warm and
they look nice but like this is like
they are servants yeah and you want to
remind them you're a servant and wear
that tie sir but at the same time you
know I can't I just I I think it's
protective Gucci suit I think this I
think it's pretentious I agree when
people say we want to represent this
country well and we want to look
professional and clean you are correct
it is not correct in my opinion however
that that is the only way to do it
fetterman is not professional there we
agree wearing that suit is not the only
way to be a professional and so we
should have respect for people who who
represent this country in other ways as
a brief aside yeah do you know why
fetterman doesn't wear suits it's a
gimmick he's worn his suits on a few
occasions and it it's a gimmick like we
were saying I doubt he wears it at home
I mean why are you wearing a hoodie and
shorts It's contradictory yeah it's not
it's still right it's it's an oxymoron I
knew a bunch of girls who would wear
like the mini skirts and Ugg boots and
it would make all of our female teachers
so mad that like if you're cold wearing
Ugg boots why are you wearing a skirt I
wear a short shirt but can I wear these
gloves yeah you don't need gloves right
now bro I don't know man weird that's
just my thing whatever all right we're
gonna go to super chats everyone if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and become a member by going to
timcast.com that is specifically
go to timcast.com click join us and that
is how you become a member some people
often confuse YouTube membership with
timcast.com membership I want to make
sure that's clear at timcast.com there
will be a members only uncensored show
coming up at 10 pm where we will talk
about things that are not so family
friendly and also take calls from you
the members and as a member you will be
a part of the the our Discord Community
for those that don't know what that is
it means you are in basically a social
network space where you're hanging out
and talking in real time with other
people who have similar ideas to you or
believe in similar things maybe disagree
with you you'll have conversations the
the members are really awesome they've
started their own shows their own
pre-shows their own after show so I
really recommend you guys check this out
it's a whole lot of fun let's uh read
your super chats
Noah Sanders says finally got my silver
beanie that's the YouTube membership
silvermani can't wait for the Miami show
in less than three weeks it's going to
be great to meet Tim Luke Ian and other
Elite members that's right the elite
membership for timps.com is 100 bucks a
month we created it because we thought
why not if you don't want if you don't
want to spend that to support the work
we do and be involved you don't have to
but for those that do we try to keep you
involved as much as possible so uh in
Miami we're gonna have a 3 P.M meet and
greet for elite members only you'll need
to take it to the event well actually no
I'm not so sure you will if you're in
Miami and you're not going to the event
but you're elite member I'm pretty sure
that's totally fine like I don't know
why we would tell you not to come but
the general idea was it was like you
might need a ticket I don't I can't say
too much okay I'm I'm revealing too much
you might need to take it you might
understand what I'm trying to say here
so uh but yes we're gonna do a big
hangout it's gonna be super awesome I
think we're going to be doing like a
catering thing and we're gonna have a
lot of fun
so yeah man really appreciate it Noah
and uh looking forward to seeing
everybody there
cat facts super chatted saying cats can
jump up to six times their height wow
that's really great I just want to give
a shout out to Baldur's Gate 3 and the
uh ability to speak to animals because
you can talk to all the animals it's
hilarious yeah I gave three of my
characters that ability and you talk
just in case it's really funny because
the dogs the girls you name it you go to
a dog and the dog's like hello friend I
hope you're I hope you're doing well and
you go to the cats and they're like
servant help I'm not kidding you talk to
the cat and it's like seventh please I
need food like I'm I'm dead serious it's
really funny like that's what they think
cats are thinking and they probably are
dogs I have two cats that think they're
dogs do you have a dog too I have four
dogs that the cats only have ever that
my two cats have only ever been around
dogs and humans they don't they don't
they do so many dog-like things that I
don't think they figured it out yet they
they lay with the dogs they eat at the
same time as the dogs they try to go out
the dog door it's like they're puppies
two dog cats yeah they are all right
right Max Redick says Tim you got to
have Destiny back on to debate Joe
Biden's corruption regarding the quid
pro quo he's heard the arguments but
isn't buying it yes I just watched a
two-hour video of Destiny on his channel
which you should watch from I think it's
yesterday of a guy just explaining
everything from 2014 and I I watched
about 40 minutes of it so far no he's
he's writing it down as the guy's
explaining it to him and we should have
the guy that explained it to him on the
show because he knows everything
everything you know so much but what is
Destiny's response do you say I watched
about 30 days like just just keep don't
worry about Donald Trump because the
guy's like and I should point out that
that if this happened with Trump Jr he's
like don't worry about that just my
brain is open I want the information
yeah and the title is Destiny here's the
conserve a pill or whatever and it's
pretty it's wonderfully entertaining not
only to see someone learning but to have
the data it is not a conservative
position to point out Joe Biden did
these things these are fact-based things
Joe Biden got uh okay let's let's start
from the beginning Hunter Biden calls DC
and says we need help dealing with a
prosecutor who's in investigating
barisma
shortly after that call I think it was a
few days or it might have been a week
Biden flies to the Flies to Ukraine and
says if you don't fire the prosecutor
you're not getting a billion dollars
under what Authority does Joe Biden do
this well the argument is under the
president's Authority okay sure fine
whatever
the prosecutor gets fired later assigns
a sworn affidavit saying he was fired
because he was investigating barisma
where the son of Joe Biden was on the
board let's pause right there what do we
have here at the bare minimum Joe Biden
engaged in a conflict of interest should
have not been involved in Ukraine so
long as his son was involved as well he
tells that story too out of his own
mouth he goes that's right he he
it's on video he tells that story the
bare minimum we have if the story was
literally just as Joe Biden explained it
and nothing else it's a conflict of
interest and it should have been stopped
and should be investigated and if that's
all it is fine so be it but considering
Devin Archer and Tony babylinski have
already testified that Biden was
influenced peddling using a son as a
proxy effectively testified to that
degree Devin Archer saying that Hunter
Biden was selling the brand saying my
dad's the VP this is what you get than
being Hunter being told to make the call
to protect the company Joe Biden was
very much involved plus then you have
Hunter Biden saying his dad takes you
have the email where he says 10 for the
big guy we know exactly what's going on
for anyone to hear these things then be
like no they're just lying to you
they're outright just saying to your
face they don't care there's Bank
documents too you could see oh no the
bank documents and then they even have
it broken down to the list of things
that he spent the money on at he did
housework on his Delaware property he
did housework on a beach property he
they have it down to like they found the
money they found where it all went and
they found where it all went out to it's
like a money Trail hard the the video on
Destiny's channel is called Destiny
wipes away his opinion on Biden takes
conservative pill it's from four days
ago
he's a grifter he's like you don't
realize but he's like sticking with it
it's badass no the thing about Destiny
is that he very very much does have hard
liberal uh moral perspectives and has no
problem saying them outright he agrees
on the facts so we get along I think
he's great he comes and hangs out and
then we're like we'll talk about
something we're playing poker and we'll
say something he's like well of course
but here's what I think and I'm like how
could you have that moral opinion he's
like as I do for example
the first time he came on he made a
comment about the covid uh policies they
were the policies they implemented using
covid during using the crisis as as an
excuse to steamroll things through and
his response wasn't no that never
happened it was when else would you do
it and so it's like he understands the
fact
when covet happened they steamrolled in
policies exploiting the crisis my my
view is that's an immoral thing to do
his his view was
when else would they do it they need to
implement change this is the perfect
time and I'm like that's interesting and
he's totally honest about his his views
morally and I okay we disagree on that
that's fine you're allowed to so I'm a
big fan I look I'll I'll check that out
it's good all right Matt Kinder says I'm
heading to Miami so I can ask Hannah
Claire to marry me and I get to meet
Trump Jr as well what a day I can't wait
she might say no just be prepared oh
yeah I'm just gonna direct all inquiries
to uh Dane font on Twitter and also just
like send her Diaries to my dad you know
and uh well you know and actually
because because of the metoo movement
several ghosts you know we're gonna have
to tell you that you're not allowed to
do that but Carter will be there and you
can certainly propose to him because
he's a guy so it's not a me too thing no
yeah yeah I guess
all right let's grab some more Super
chats
Jeremy Paul says first time being able
to make it by eight love the show keep
doing what you're doing please ask Phil
and these fellas about their thoughts on
brrf 2023 love the rock shine I keep up
the work guys are you familiar with that
well Blue Ridge oh is that Blue Ridge
Rockfest yeah yeah were you guys there
no we weren't there we had a great
experience last year you guys were
really awesome yeah it was awesome
amazing wow all right thank you we had a
great time with you guys and and our
experience was great throwing the
drumstick in the air as he was playing
with amazing posture Trevor's posture's
incredible it's Yoga Yoga he does got
great posture no yoga but we we didn't
we didn't go either I mean so you were
saying there's hail Dodge the bullet
yeah we didn't go so this is hearsay
like I wasn't there but um the tour
we're on right now the sound guy is the
uh dang who who was the uh who was he
doing the sound for
um I don't remember it was
Black Label society's guitar player
maybe I don't know
um
that's a disaster he was there he was
there and he didn't even leave this
hotel because he said that there was a
ton of hell and they had to cancel the
whole thing the whole thing the whole
thing they moved locations from last
year which last year was you were there
yeah even though it was raining it was
very smooth all the bands were on time
all the bands got to play it was great
this year they moved locations they had
trouble shuttling people to and from the
show and uh there was really horrible
weather so I I support Blue Ridge
Rockville yeah they treat us great and I
really hope they bounce back from this
if you're a fan listen and don't give up
on them give them another chance it was
a lot of fun last year fun Festival they
don't control the weather you know yeah
control the window independently owned
you know for now until yeah that's great
it's massive I got to see Gwar and
tenacious I think I think today was
right after guar every time a corporate
entity buys one of these things we get
exiled Natalie this way is the first man
out seriously we used to do a couple of
big ones and then and then the corporate
faction it gets so successful the
corporate uh monsters come in and they
buy the festival and then and then that
next year I'm like hey we doing we doing
ink on the clinking and they're like nah
man it got bought out you'll never Play
It Again wow yeah
yeah we got to do our own we got to do
one we got some stuff working on the
background uh we're uh putting together
a convention okay I won't say too much
until we get the ball rolling on it but
we're looking at areas is an area
probably out here in in some some part
of that beautiful where we can get a big
enough space but we want to do all right
I'm just going to say it anyway the
preliminary stuff is we want to do
um
an independent media and parallel
economy convention where it's it's
basically we've got this growing uh this
growing space of all these independent
content creators across the board from
uh Sports Science politics you name it
and so I'm like I mean we should have a
place where once a year everybody comes
together and we build that Community you
know we're doing this thing in
Martinsburg where we want to it's
preliminary as well but uh we're having
a meeting about in a couple days to
invest in a bunch of businesses and set
up brick and mortar shops for these
parallel economy businesses these
companies that Public Square supports
and that support Public Square it's a
great idea and then I'm thinking like
well what about like we might have that
cool little you know strip of downtown
where people can hang out and go to
cousin T's Diner and get some Casper
coffee maybe a slice of pizza at Papa
Jack's but what about a once a year
convention
and it's like okay well you know let's
find a place where we can something so
so it's very very preliminary but that's
the the general idea get Brilliant Minds
together too culture like you know
exactly rewards get Brilliant Minds
together think about we're the think
Tech they're meeting in Davos those two
thousand to come up with plans why can't
we meet somewhere come up with our plans
we're so smart the people's got good
games you know yeah people put that
aside from that we should we should make
our own music festival we should I mean
we should start we got to start making
these things I have those days where
like people are talking to panel system
at night have musical performances for
people who are in the space Oh like they
kick on sex or something yeah what would
be a good amount of bands to get for
like a solid Festival day or weekend
Trevor does all the scheduling so you
can just go through the schedule in your
mind
I'd say like 15 bands probably to one
day bands yeah but we do we let's say we
do a convention out here somewhere on
the East Coast somewhere you know
Appalachia we find a big enough Center
maybe we start small we start small we
expect a couple thousand attendees or
something and then we get some bands
interlaced with speakers and it's just
it's just like two or three days you
look at at what like Charlie Kirk does
and they got massive stuff going on but
I think you could have some massive too
I think that there's a movement right
now I think bands used to be super like
when we used to walk into a room early
on because we were kind of like it had
this kind of mindset years back uh we
were like The Outsiders everywhere we
went in the music industry but now we're
noticing that we're showing up and
there's there's bands that are more
like-minded us I think they're some of
the biggest bins too I think a band you
you could have a band like shine down or
you know Phil's band too like there's
big there's more of a culture coming up
that I think would fit in with what
you're talking about in a festival so it
could be bigger because you could just
get the right act to headline it who
feels passionately like we all do look
at at Blue Ridge one of the coolest
moments that happened is is because I
think they lost power there's a viral
video going where Shinedown got on a
stage with their acoustic guitars and
they played their one of their biggest
hits Second Chance in front of a
thousands thousands of people no PA
everyone's shouting the lyrics back at
them and Oliver Anthony is on stage with
them playing you know his guitar and
that was a super cool moment I wonder if
Billy Corgan would come Smashing
Pumpkins yeah probably yeah he's super
cool yeah yeah oh they're so good man
every time I hear pumpkins they're
getting like better and better too
always I don't know I'm enjoying it more
or if Billy is just more woke up I have
a I have a first edition Siamese Dream
vinyl
you know what you two have some stuff in
common with songwriting you you do your
own thing and he was all about that man
when you listen to him talk about
songwriting he's like I want to do
things that are different I want to go
and be myself and try all these change
like he he was very very sometimes when
I hear your songwriting and when I
listen to you your writing reminds me of
of Billy's would be cool I met him I met
him once he's uh uh he signed a poster
for me and he it was it's a crazy story
because I met him all excited he was
like you're Tim pool and I was like whoa
like this is a crazy day for me I was I
was this was several years ago but I'm a
huge fan I've grew up listening to
Smashing Pumpkins like one of my
favorite bands but let's read some more
we got uh Adrian horta Martinez says Tim
and team first Super Chat been here
since the beginning Montgomery Texan
here can you make a segment or shed
light on the taranos Houston Story by
daily wire Greg Abbott sold us out
letting us letting a city be built
specifically for in legal wow for
illegal immigrants that is cartel run
and backed whoa well we need to do that
thing where we have like you Hannah
Claire do the breakdown of the Biden
scandal yeah I'm done so we should
figure it out I mean it's up to you if
you want to write if you want to write
like
a long-form breakdown of like these big
events yeah I'll just have you record it
and then have someone edit a video yeah
I'm down let's do it all right well
there you go there you go okay coming
soon
right on
let's grab some more Super chats Karsten
Ellsworth said they did the same thing
to Justin royland with Rick and Morty he
lost everything due to allegations that
didn't end up being true why cancel
before evidence yup dude that's crazy
too and they're like we're gonna keep
doing Rick and Morty without Justin
Roiland how he's the voice of Rick and
Morty that's it have they done one yet I
don't know it's gonna go downhill if you
get rid of a guy you get rid of the
Creator you get rid of the the heart and
soul of the project it's just gonna
you're gonna be able to tell it's like
one Game of Thrones went off course and
started writing the ending of the series
without the books and you were like you
could just immediately tell us like
episode one well this is worse man dude
like the part where it's like they fly a
dragon across the entire continent in an
hour it's just like did they think about
what was going on from the north wall
All the Way South like this is stupid
logic went out the window sound familiar
dude the new Rick and Morty is gonna be
hilarious because you're gonna get it's
gonna show Morty it's gonna be like hey
I'm Morty and then Rick's like oh Morty
I'm Rick and you're gonna be like what
is this this is weird I wonder if
they'll use AI Rock they'll be like
awesome cereal they're probably rapidly
trying to build the AI program right now
to mimic rylan's voice and like we own
the rights it needs to be put an end to
the the the the the the guilty right out
the gate needs to go away stop now it
needs to be innocent until proven guilty
and that's it that's huge dude
supporting innocence is such a big part
of what we're going through right now
bro I'm willing to bet that I can drop
Rick's voice Justin Rollins uh voice
into 11 labs and it will give us Rick
but we'll do this in the members only
show because I'm we're in Super Chips
now and we're gonna talk about AI anyway
so as we're talking about the AI stuff I
will attempt to clone the voice of
Justin Roiland and I think it'll take 30
seconds I seriously think it'll take 30
seconds let's read some more Super chats
well full sense I said I had a Twitter
poll I had a poll on Twitter today and
25 of the people that took my bowl were
graped by Russell Russell Brand
oh I see right now you've got a lot more
allegations to add to the list huh
neurodivergence says Dear Ian you are
the Canada of timcast IRL sincerely a
Canadian just a friendly Ally to the
north that's right Canada's Got a great
culture I say that because I am Canadian
I love Canada vacation there our pieces
who would win in a fight Bruce Lee
versus Tarzan scenario jungle clearing
no weapons I'm sorry that's a bad
question it's Bruce Lee no question no
why would Tarzan when he's had no
fighting experience but he hides in the
trees no and now get out of here like
dude we're talking about jungle clearing
and no weapons so it's an open space
Tarzan's going to be strong but Bruce
Lee's strong and trained to fight you're
talking about one you're talking about a
martial artist that's some of the
greatest martial artists in the world
emulate you got guys like Anderson Silva
Conor McGregor these guys were obsessed
with Bruce Lee because he was so good at
martial arts you know Bruce Lee was so
fast they had to slow the camera down
normally during these movies they would
speed things up to make the action look
faster and stronger but Bruce Lee was
too fast may have been all the math he
was doing you know I'm not sure I think
it was math whatever Google it
yeah I think let me just taking a lot of
B12 no I think it wasn't that it that he
was like doing meth a lot I don't know
are you looking it up yeah
was it meth
my brother does meth and he's slower
than ever well yeah because it breaks
you right unless cannabis uh revealed by
Robert Baker okay so he's doing coke
well that could do it his wife told
Robert Baker that he was doing coke LSD
and cannabis that makes sense so I read
that his his brain was swelling or
something that's how he died and some
may have he used to like electrocute
himself too
so he did drugs to get into character
for movies like is he tripping on LSD
while he was doing that oh man wild all
right Rob says Aaron Lewis have stained
and Sean Danielson of Smile Empty Soul
would be some pretty Base guest to have
on it would also be cool to hear from
them and Phil talk about the time in the
industry Aaron Lewis is going to be out
here uh soon they're both my friends man
you know you know Aaron Lewis
he's actually going to be here he's
going to be at uh Hollywood Charlestown
uh y'all should come out and check out
his show man because it's a really great
venue for a show like um
uh
for uh Aaron Lewis I'm Googling at the
same time sorry uh here we go let me
pull up the dates here we'll give a
shout out to him uh December 1st he's
going to be here December 1st and 2nd
he's going to be at Hollywood Casino at
Charlestown Races in Charlestown West
Virginia it's about an hour outside of
DC y'all should come uh he's been out
here before but I I was I was thinking
about this too I'm like trying it would
be cool to get in touch with him and see
if while he's out here I don't know what
his tour I can connect you guys I can
get it done hit him up I mean that would
be an honor that'd be so amazing if we
could have him on the show around that
time I'll make the connection stuff
though because he might have to leave
before let's let's try to make it happen
that'd be so amazing Sean from Smile
Empty would definitely come on well yeah
we're looking to do a tour together so
I've been talking to him yeah these are
two guys that I that I that I feel like
I can maybe connect the dots if you want
to do it to it man let's read some more
we got Brandon Smith this is over 90
percent of corn soybeans and sugar beets
in the US are genetically modified oh
yeah don't you love it and not
genetically modified in the sense where
they cross select plants to breed for
like seedlessness or something we're
talking about inject acting E coli or
whatever into the into the plant itself
to alter its genetic yeah like what we
picked off your tree in the backyard
nothing like that you know we're that's
hop on dude come on yeah I'm gonna go
smash a few of those later on yeah so
it's it's like you can just peel them
right open it's amazing and then just
yeah it's nuts dude I couldn't imagine
you know if you if if it's 200 300 years
ago just living out here you're like I
can't wait for September when the food
is just literally everywhere oh yeah so
we've got wild grapes everywhere they're
they're called Frost grapes so they
taste they taste super tart but uh
they're okay they're pretty good we get
Berry season you get a bunch of fruits
we got pears it's just there's so much
fruit we might as well be living on a
farm it's at Thanksgiving they made a
holiday because it was so wondrous when
you didn't starve at the end of the yeah
you guys got nothing to worry about man
when I'm glad that you that you inform
people you inform people on what's going
on out there but you are away from the
hustle and bustle you've got fruit
growing in your backyard there are no I
don't think there's anything uh to fret
over here the only thing outside I got
like 20 deer this around this property
yes the downside is I don't feel a pulse
on the the nature of humanity very well
out here I feel isolated we do yeah but
bro bro the the pulture uh the pulcher
the the pulse on the culture of humanity
is not in cities
people are people have isolated
themselves they don't talk to their
neighbors that's not the pulse of
humanity
everyone has like three jobs right now
that's where we've yeah we've realized
from our fans our fans all have three
jobs they're working multiple jobs
multiple fans of ours uh we're retired
and have come out of retirement yeah
that's the unemployment numbers people
I've had to go back to work we are on
the ground in America on a van you know
we have a sprinter van we drive it
across the whole country we stay in
hotels we've been we've done a hundred
dates by the end of this run we'll do a
hundred dates for the year so over the
last 15 years we have the pulse on the
United States and it's worse than I've
ever seen it and we can't let that bake
into our minds because we got to turn it
around it's time to turn it around we
can't let negativity win this battle to
where we fall into a negative mindset
and it just keeps getting more negative
we got to turn it around right now we've
got to understand where we're at we see
the pulse the U.S it's in a negative
Direction it's time to kick it into gear
become United be a swarm of bees instead
of One Singular bee together
the prop they'll run man one bees
bugging you you can slap it away 50 bees
are coming at you you run we need it all
stick together come together and and and
set the tone for the future for us right
now we're not going to accept the
direction that we're heading in right
now it's not good on the ground we got
one just for you guys walking later says
I love adelita's ways song Get It On
however it sounds really distorted I'd
pay for a remastered version that has a
better sound quality
is that like an older song or something
or yeah that's not what she's listening
on yeah it's probably something we just
put out too you know I like that song
too and and uh sometimes we we go in the
studio and we make what we want and it
sounds really different and then it and
it doesn't make a record or it doesn't
make you know our plans and then
eventually we put it out for our fans
because it's you get into the mode of
like why not right you let them hear it
so I think get it on it just it just
yeah the budget might not have been the
highest for that song that it could have
been made that needs to be remastered I
don't know I'll look into that that's
good you never know because I hear all
these stories where it's like the band
says this is it this is our hit song
they put it out and no one cares and
then they're like well here's a b side
and then boom number one and they're
like damn always happens yeah like well
I guess that's one people like you know
I thought that was a danger of
experimenting as a musician is if you
create an experiment that hits the top
then you're like well I don't know how I
made that one that crazy weird thing now
I've got to try and do you ever get that
fear and just end up staying in a lane
that's like I know they like it my
biggest I have the opposite fear I want
to go in the studio I still want to
write the best song in the world every
time I go in the studio oh I've got that
kind of like challenge for myself I'd
love to to write just the greatest song
that exists at that moment in time a
Timeless song
um but I think what scares me is
what if you had your whole career
where your songs were what they were and
then you covered a song and the cover
song became your biggest song that's my
fear it happened to my uncle's band I
don't I don't that's that's uh I think
that's uh orgy and shiny toy guns I
think that's good for them so many bands
it's so many bands and it's good for
them but as far as my personal Legacy it
would bum me out if I looked at my
catalog of seven records and the number
one top most listened to new songs one I
didn't write it would it would kind of
make me like be like yeah my bro bro
even of these top songs were they even
written by the person who performed them
probably not some of them are some some
like it's an easier way in the industry
to to cover a smash I'm not saying that
I'm saying like an artist will be given
a song by a production company saying
like we wrote this song it's really good
and you're the person to perform like
Max Martin he was Notorious to give the
the Backstreet Boys and bring oh yeah
every song he wrote them all my uncle's
band in the 70s Tim Huey he was a
Michael aylward the lead singer they hit
it big with a monkey's cover and never
went anywhere it never really went
anywhere they had a Sony I think it was
Sony deal two records but it was just so
popular the cover the already Awesome
song and they were like Devo they didn't
really have like uh it was that weird
Akron sound they had going on well I'll
tell you this though for for in a lot of
ways if you're I would rather go see a
cover band than like most local bands
that's a good well look you go to a
Barcia cover band you're gonna hear a
bunch of songs you know and like live in
person and it's fun and it's like you're
going to the actual show of the band who
wrote it like if you want to go see Muse
perform you go see music perform if
you're hanging out with your friends and
they have a cover band playing it's
going to be fun especially if they do
requests like I've seen like you guys
have probably seen live band karaoke oh
yeah but if like if my friends say like
Hey we're gonna go on Friday night
there's a show and I'm like by who and
they're gonna name some like three
random bands they'll be like I have no
disrespect to these bands I mean I just
don't know who they are and they're a
fun nights the the con I think that's
one thing that's getting lost a little
bit like we're we're at the concerts
every night they're fun they're fun
nights out and I think sometimes people
lose you know everyone gets so drawn
into oh what type of music is a raw
country like look at look at a country
concert
there's 20 000 people some of these
shows and then somehow Rock got a bad
name but the rock concerts are fun man
we play them every night and we look out
there and we're like dude people are
missing out sometimes we we think that
the nights are so fun people are missing
out man this is the thing people ready
to go out and and interact and meet
people that like people used to go do
stuff yeah you know what you know what's
really really crazy about music because
I grew up in it I grew up in an age of
recordings we all did recordings and
then MP3s
yo back in the I was watching um movies
I watched and I was watching that thing
you do it's like back in the day
listening to music was going out it was
like I want to hear music I can't hear
it unless I go out somewhere yeah like
you can't even like so they have radio
eventually and songs play on the radio
and you're sitting there being like man
I really want to hear that one song by
that band but I guess I'll get lucky if
they play it before this it was like
you liked music it was only on the
weekends at night and someone had to
play it for you nowadays it's just
ubiquitous it's like great as um as an
Entertainer to go to like as a musician
to go to a rock concert because I think
we learn primarily through mimicry
humans you know by hearing or seeing and
then reproducing so like I hear your
song it's cool but when I see you
perform it now I know how you did it and
I can mimic that yeah I've seen you guys
play alive there's no question it's it's
a hundred fold better than a record we
love what we do recordings can't capture
it dude like I was saying like you're
throwing the drumstick in the air like
the whole performance and everything is
just man Indescribable I I know from
playing with with the band for as long
as we play together we have a connection
up there sometimes when I'm up there I
have to make it a point to start looking
fans on the eyes because I'm having too
much fun with my friends up there you
know I got to be like all right they're
here it's been rocking out with Trevor
too much you gotta back off let's go and
sing to some people you know like
because you just get up there and and uh
and we're really driven too we I think
that our our mindset has been positive
about being in a band like you meet
we've met people in bands who their
dreams have come true and they're so
negative and they're so bummed out and
I'm like dude what are you so negative
and bummed out for you you travel the
country you do your dream and you're so
bummed out and we've met that and we
promised ourselves we would never be
like that so we make the best of every
day and we've done that for almost 20
years make the best of every day I'm
like what's it look like he's like we're
gonna party the way we party man let's
go do what we do and we try to find all
the things we like to do we make sure
the performance that we put on we're
having fun up there on stage and we
never lose sight of the gratitude that I
that we have for our jobs you guys get
in the Flow State when you're performing
oh yeah oh yeah let's uh let's grab one
more here Aaron Richard says there's a
middle ground here slacks and a nice
golf shirt or a half zip over a button
the five suit rule by Steve Harvey gets
75 suit options every young man needs to
know this info very resourceful
yeah and I I think the compromise is
telling people to be clean and to wear
pants and to try and look presentable
and nice but I don't think there should
be a set standard on like it is this or
nothing
I don't think a suit is the only way to
be a professional and to look
professional because that implies that
people who do business deals CEOs uh
lawyers basically it implies that white
collar is professional and nothing else
or it implies that blue collar
professionals are not welcome in a space
only white collar professionals I just
don't like that idea there's a lot of
people who do other jobs that are
professional and they do more important
jobs I'm sorry man I think most
blue-collar jobs are more important than
most white-collar jobs that's just it
I would I if if I was on an island
and then if I was gonna be stranded an
island I'm on a boat and it's like only
one there's there's two boats and
they're like save me you know save me as
a lawyer and it's a mechanic I'm like
mechanic has more real world practical
skills to help me survive in this island
the lawyer though the plumber is coming
with me let's go you know how to do
electricity and the best part is the
plumber is gonna be like I got two
morons who talk for a living
between me and the lawyer oh yeah so
I'll take the mechanic I just gotta fire
Super Chat from Phil that remains give
the Adelitas Way boys my best been
listening on the drive back right on
thanks Phil all right everybody
here buddy smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends go to timcast.com
click join us we're gonna have a members
only uncensored show we're gonna
experiment with some AI stuff it's gonna
be a whole lot of fun we'll make some AI
pictures and talk about the AI
apocalypse on its way and the latest
developments you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast do you guys want to shout
anything out edely's way yes please
we're on tour right now with our friends
in drowning pool in salab in any given
sin we are our YouTube is almost at 100
000 subscribers so please follow us on
YouTube help us get that little
our little plaque we're looking forward
to it so you follow us I don't know if
the album's been in the shot for the
show but you should pull that down and
show people because this is nasty
looking yeah I'm gonna get one of these
nasty is that good or bad that's a good
thing we'll be in Baltimore tomorrow if
you guys want to uh venture to That Fun
Place what time what time are you
probably go on around 8 p.m at Rams Head
live right on AW vinyl baby this is what
this whole thing was we were bringing
back live music that we were the
superheroes bringing back live music we
were the first band back on tour from
coven right that's awesome where do
people get that people get the vinyl
yeah you got to come to a show
welcome to the concerts right on right
on we got uh yeah uh well I'm here I'm
writer for timcast.com you should follow
at timcast news on X and Instagram can I
say what I'm doing in Miami when I'm
there yeah okay so uh Josie the redhead
libertarian I are gonna sit down with
Michael Seifert the Public Square CEO so
I hope you guys are all coming to Miami
because I think it'll be really fun it's
right before IRL so something else to
check out and I'm really excited to be
on stage with her because she's great if
you want to follow me personally I'm on
Twitter at hcrimo and on Instagram
handclare.b thank you so much and then
after that Alex Stein will be doing a
15-minute set which is going to be
really good what time you and Josie go
live you know what time that starts I
think it's like six but I don't know you
should just buy our tickets and come
well it's not going to be live no we're
not live but we're on stage so we're
exclusive to the event which I think is
pretty cool I just want to shout out
adelita's way power the newest single or
one of the newest singles I don't know
if they're all and I want people to
check it out I was saying on this with
you guys it was awesome and I hope we do
it again we should do it again pretty
soon let's do it again a little more get
even more integrated next time song lock
ourselves in the studio man holler back
at you Ricky love it every minute baby
check it out power where do people get
it on iTunes everywhere check it out
soon Spotify follow whatever power is is
it's doing great man a visceral yeah I
like it yeah fun all right Carter I
enjoy the song too I helped track some
of Ian's harmonies and once again thank
you guys for coming down I still
remember Rick when you sang Happy
Birthday to a fan at Blue Ridge Rockfest
last year thought that was particularly
cool so yeah follow our latest way
follow Tim cast songs on YouTube go to
trashhouse.com and get Bright Eyes some
of our other songs are coming out and if
you want to follow me personally you can
follow me at Carter banks on Twitter
Carter banks4l on Instagram where I post
pictures of my cat right on all right
everybody we will see you all over at
timcast.com in about a minute or so
thanks for hanging out